hi there I go in a bit I'm actually making
coffee making coffee
all right
I got to come so tonight we're going to have
is to make a is to create a melting point
hours to create an additional volume
additional files are some additional disc on
these new virtual machines to get created
where he done it once or going to use
normally we just have disk for this
but what I want to do is see if there is a
way
to do it with the vagrant file disk
directive
so if we go we got discontinued all right
have a look at Thanksgiving duration
this time zone
this DVD floppy this is new by the way he's
such a pain in the provider we have we know
that some
virtualbox provider provides all this
and yeah we were able to do all this
yeah that's interesting
I understand what I just meant I didn't have
to provide the file and it just made it
automatically
as interesting you and so
and I want to see if we can actually cause
it to format
don't think that's because something we can
do through the through it vacant Rosanna
Couture do that for the Proviso provide
provisioning
it was his response was the following
categories for the best the best you can do
is 2 it's kind of loud music
how's it going I'm in Lenox welcome so
I don't want to sound to something for you
at the sound there
so it's so basically what we would be doing
is dealing with discs and
I want to know if they did take it to the
do you work out of Hickory the file system
that runs on the disc
configure discipline of disrespect to the
reader right action of this metafile are you
did
oh that's nice
yeah it's it's pretty fun if you're on Linux
you probably know more about NFS than I do
it's been a long time since it's an
interface I'm done it since the 90s
so are you familiar with vagrant
pickets for provisioning virtual machines
dynamically
this pedophile both built-in disc actions if
he's going to just expect to be read right
inside the machines dated rectory keep track
of the last configured steak for decillion
brighter
I forgot my sweater maker that uses the file
to see what this work to figure to last run
oh yeah we need to play with that Tony while
I really want to play with that I get 10 if
this stuff finishing tomorrow I'm going to
be doing that a lot
we should talk about that oh my gosh
yeah well we should
a real to send a note and you weren't able
to tap into it and send him a reference to
it it's nice if it is no longer verify like
can be assumed they just kind of over there
hey how's it going
manticore
it's going to be required for provider help
her with virtualbox reserve a car needs a
way to help you track with your find a
Spanish word vagrant
and are you IDs
Panabaker
when you do it when you do answer will stuff
do you how do you provision of EMS we've
been talking a lot about that
I thought seriously about doing that but
vagrants to do everything I want one shot
right
anthem of the sea right I understand I just
don't know how
reminder name
size primary name file
discount extension of charger that has what
kind of file extension have
okay I think I got everything all right so
I'm actually good news because you see how
hard it is to practice provisioning a hard
drive with fdisk this is so fun Amelie huge
for education
and I'm not sure why I didn't really Embrace
this more before
because this allows me to do things that are
just like totally taboo and dangerous
anywhere else that can't be done with
containers so this is definitely a huge huge
tool vagrant Vigor to like vagrant
I'm starting to think that big run is Benson
tastic
hint after stocks are good yeah
you know them all nice thank you here we're
going to try to keep it fun in 2020 be doing
a lot of planning for 20 20 20 22 coming up
here
oh that's nice of said to say that I
appreciate it so let me let me show you
something this is at this point I am really
seriously thinking about
adding this and I in a serious way
is it let me let me go ahead and run this
vagrant up so here's a necrophile
and just a recap for everybody have to make
sure to export bigger experimental this is
what I was losing before there are two
different ways the old way and the new way
for provisioning disk through vagrant the
new way uses the really awesome disc thing
this year but it doesn't work without
exploiting his experimental it works fine
but it's listed as experimental and he noted
that way there's another way to do it but
you have to do like you have to make calls
to the provider which is kind of a pain in
the butt but you can do it
and so this says this is this Loop for a
permission so different
workers this is actually really good and
Ruby Syntax for the scything and here's
where we defend everything and we're pulling
down the same M8 which I understand is the
best bet and red hat Enterprise non Red Hat
red hat
and then we have the hostname to them and
give him a virtualbox
I'll give him CPR memory and disc and the
disk is not under the provider Loop
hi how's it going so and then this is I
can't tell you how valuable this is because
by doing this I can provision one 10 or 20
different discs and I can I could set those
disks have been in a raid 5 simulation I
could do whatever I wanted to I can create
raw Blockhead block devices for a database
if I wanted to test it that way and sitting
sitting up discs and praising him in
virtualbox is not an easy task using the
gooey you can do it right but it's it's very
complicated this is so much easier this way
you can kind of script into the says give
and give if the if the note is control give
it a 10 MB it's the really small so I can
fill it up and see what happens when it gets
too full and then go ahead and and run the
provision script on everything
and the provision script is is here going to
turn swap off just cuz we don't need it and
this is going to go ahead and sell the NFS
utils because we're going to put in if
that's on your eventually but we're also
going to automatically format and place a
file system on the disk volume that we just
attached and I'll do that now so
house for sale get it provisioning so any
regular up
oh I left a comment I like him a lot he's
never once treated me but I really love him
it's time to go that way I'm just a
small-time friends well
alright so let's go ahead and but I'm just
sitting up
I forgot my coffee I'm going to pack
yeah I forgot I Mike I definitely did so
it's like
I love this is this this Stillness of the
software is being created
what they mean by infrastructure as
codestructures code
you know it it's actually running
we look to run the run some code and to
actually make to make virtual machines or
simulated Hardware
and that's a big deal it's like a really big
deal
so you know you can't escape learning how to
code coding is everywhere it really is you
know
and what are you whether you're like a
terminal junkie like us or you just doing
something else
the steps at this coat is doing to create
these were some issues for us pretty amazing
I just think this is a nominal I know it
looks boring but you have no idea how cool I
think this is
I am here because this is going to let us
test using some of the most dangerous
commands known to Lenox and I'm not talking
about our msrf I'm talking about things like
Didi and fdisk scary scary commands
I wonder I wonder if Will is running if we
could kind of be kind of the hood
I want to and it writes in here are this
machines right control there's our machines
what are these things
why is Yuki scary scary Jack idea he's one
of the few commands you can totally nuke
your break your computer. Break it you can
not the reason for my entire hard drive you
cancel this break your heart right now
depends on the NBA already know how much you
can restore from that and if you need it the
master boot record
I recovered this before by grabbing an NBR
off another disk and rewriting it to another
disk secret is to survive so then we are 144
B I think the beginning of every disc
if you happen to be are in a the B used to
be the boot record from this I think that
some of that discard to texture is change
then point I was trying to make is that
experimenting with this architecture is
extremely dangerous and time-consuming on
hardware and that's how I learned we had to
get old disks write and I'd have my chassis
open on my table and I'm plugging in a new
you know old school ID driving before scuzzy
right we can plug in a new ribbon cable I
plug the drive-in and I'd fuck around with
Dad and I try to get to reformat it and then
I would then I would break it and I'll get
another disc going to put that in there and
I try to get that was how you that was how
you messed around with with learning how to
provision disc in and formatted and copy it
off and everything that was steps I did it
it if you wanted to experiment with Linux
and get you know dirty and down and dirty
with some of the more dangerous commands it
involve disk space and Ayo and and stuff
like that you had to do it with Hardware
and so a lot of Linux people from my
generation had Hardware everywhere
with Hardware I still have I still have
probably 15 IDE drive just sitting in a
drawer
yeah yeah if you can imagine I was so mad
Dragon 2000 actually have the box I bought
Mandrake in a box
so
how's it going off so don't you have the
back then the back then you had to play
then you had to play with Hardware in order
to test all this stuff and now now I can run
a script I mean seriously how fucking cool
is it that I can resist taking longer than
usual I'm wondering why there is Serenity
way
I guess not what's an Oculus
Mandrake with Susie yeah
Dalek it was just hard to read news on
German all right so then we go so there when
I work or two is to taking longer than usual
this virtualbox it definitely takes longer
than
then then they delivered drivers but it's
more popular in mainstream
alright so so now what are we doing
I'm going to go get some
okay so here's the here's the part that's
terrifying okay there's a couple commands
that are you should to be to have a healthy
respect for
Lenox right I mean everybody uses are
disrupting her for Dad and Dede they've
heard about that they've never heard of that
if desk right this another one of those
commands that you should be we should have
healthy healthy skepticism are healthy and I
don't you don't want to just throw the Three
Stooges around so what's the first things
first let's do a loop here
and we're going to run this is a little one
liner that says run lsblk which list all the
blocks of ice has those are disk volume to
Tash devices to on the entire thing and I
want to show you the at the
as you can see this one has I hate it does
this morning I wonder if he can tell the
wake-up vagrant to do not do the warnings
owner says I can afford a car to turn off
the warnings
same old vagrant experimental
Brinks makes it hard to read
I guess so
recent photos back if you use to name every
single Smirnoff he shook his head Flygon
if you want me to do that Healdsburg future
1 and teacher 2
cloud in it enable this feature allows users
to use cloud in a future more information on
this
McKenzie providers and it was feature will
allow bigger to manage configuration too
sweet to that type triggers
I don't know I wonder how I can get it to
Icelandair picture a certification to
package
I need to get rid of it
I wonder if it writes it just it out I said
Aaron let's try
I asked you to go see your dental
and net-net take care of it
I mean wait let me try something else here
so that got rid of the errors also I had a
feeling Q is going to do it
I hope it does anyway guess not hairless
two-man vagrant
oh how you doing drugs have drafix
yeah I slept love having you all here so
this is to do there is no flag
that's too bad I can help without
I can hope without her friend autocomplete
cut a straight Hall to help and then login
operator resume I should have suspended box
that has just spent upload validate version
he is just version I think that's for bows
any online interactive output no TTY
enable debug output yeah alright fine I'll
go back to her
our humble redirect to re-direct Avenue and
Lisa Rosen don't know that God
I mean to standard out standard are lots of
people then they won't do that so this is
what I wanted to show
hey so this is Cesar the three systems
there's you know we have control and then we
have work or one or two he knows that
control has an SD be on here but it doesn't
have any petitions on it yet because it's a
volume has been created as I said in the old
days I would have to wipe a disc and plug it
in to get that hey how's it going to kiss
your python was Django I don't use either
I'm not suit a suitable person to talk to
about that
yeah I don't use those Savages go for any of
that I don't I don't I just don't know I'm
not saying don't use it I just don't know
and we haven't talked to somebody else who
uses that kind of stuff
night so let's let's do this, but this is
the fun part so we can use Bakery SSH to
connect to the control box which is the one
that's got the the volume on it right I mean
lsblk to show the blocked devices right so
another reason for doing this is let's say
let's say you don't want to try all this
stuff and you wanted to learn Linux write
what you can do all of these commands and
learn them in a virtual machine without
hurting anybody
iheartraves container how did you fantastic
is rajamanickam
do you mind if I put that really kind, and
in my in my nice things file I'm going to
anyway
the keeps me running mccd
I do I have a I have a file that I keep that
just makes me happy because God knows I'm
taking shit from people
principal telling you make entire videos
about all the reasons you shouldn't do
anything I say and then I'm going to ruin
your life if you follow me and
I've never seen you like more than an hour
of my videos
whatever we got to learn to live without
worrying about those people right
I mean I'm going to I'll jump that out 2 2 2
2 2
it's very cool that you're doing that stuff
yeah we're going to do some zettelkasten
stuff tomorrow
paragon nice
hey man. I put it in here cuz you're very
quiet I clicked on your link it didn't go
there
I don't know why but I think she's busted
add
is it in Brazil oh yeah
I love Brazil Nevaeh Paula Ferrari is like
one of my Heroes that you know this is a
thing we can we have Heroes when I say that
I'm Apollo for is my hero I do not approve
of his misogynistic anti-women rhetoric was
in the sixties when he wrote that book
I don't when you say as soon as you're here
that doesn't necessarily mean you approve of
everything you did I also think Martin
Luther King is a fantastic human being and a
great person to emulate
person to emulate and be a hero he's also a
Serial adulterer you know so I just want to
put that out there because I'm afraid people
I think that we can hear worship certain
people based on the good that they've done
and try to we can't forget the bad that
they've done because we will repeat it you
know but at the same time I think we should
focus on what people try as hard as you can
to do to focus mostly on the good and
goddamn fairy is done a lot of amazing
things
what do you think I'm going to just like
containers over like b a c
I can't speak to that directly I don't have
any direct information on that the biggest
Advantage is that they won interns employed
on billions if not trillions of different
containerized engines right now and
orchestration Frameworks so that's the
advantage advantages that is when you say
container today
99.9% of everybody who hears the word
container today think cellex-c that is the
biggest single advantage
so
that's a pretty substantial one alright so
here's the really fun things we get to do
this it here's a funky man so it was a
command call fdisk right
and what if this does is it takes a raw bit
of volume space so it's actually it warms my
heart to see fda's by the way sdarcc devices
right either schedule devices or there say
to a devices or let you know but you didn't
used to csda in DC this nvme shit right you
know about that right and if you run this
command on on any modern system is got it
like that block storage I mean it's got like
SSD you get this right and by the way this
is why people fucking hate snap like that it
melts all this packages is a root device
stupid is that so stupid loopback devices
I can't even write it yeah I can never
remember it
I look at it and I'm like what and give me
zero and blah blah blah and they got this
crazy I mean it's not as cool as you know
and then he's like really modest SDA there's
my media drive right so this is my USB stick
that's plugged in so it warms my heart to
see SDA because FDA, is the way it used to
be used to be that you know that really
basic things in your head so that so lsblk
shows you all the devices on your system as
a relatively modern thing and let's be okay
with not around when I didn't Unix before
why don't you remember how he's doing we we
would do after such a l l s is also a Linux
command I think
and if you're on a Mac you can't do these
that all
if that's that she'll know I had to do his
route which I also thought maybe we could
probably leave from Prague
right there you go so this is this is a much
easier way to do the same thing
and empty at this cuz it's pretty old
program and it's going to happen to know so
I'm going to use it
so again I am on this extra machine here so
I can do things that I normally would not do
it actually what I'm about to do is really
fun if you're new to Lenox because we're
actually going to provision our own hard
drive from the command line I mean I'm sorry
I will file system and that's what if this
does an in-form ask the file system to
accept any number of different different
about any kind of file system we want on
there right now it's just raw storage blocks
or so to the she has to do has to do I have
to ask and he has appointed to the device s
d a b Wright dentist that's a petition has
different work and do that you can sub
partition to put your file systems on there
and everything and we'll do that eventually
but right now it is it is any of this you
have this is fdisk command this command is
super scary and dangerous because if you
point it at your hard drive and you do the
wrong thing and you had the partition table
completely you could
Wheatley wipe your just now you have to just
ways of recovering stuff on your disk of
course but in terms of like getting the
exact file system back you can have a real
hard time with that so you can put it in for
help and you can look around all the
different commands
all the different commands and you can see
that there's no print out this menu change
the display enter units extra functionality
extra functionality is pretty crazy you can
like you know toggle that bit of old desks
and stuff and things like that but this this
command expects you to have pretty low-level
knowledge of file systems and I know what
they are about and how to use them and which
one to put on there and most people who jump
into fdisk when they first get going they
don't have any idea and they can create all
kinds of problems I don't know what kind of
file system put on there and it didn't know
whether the issue is NTFS or they should use
the xt2 and different so let me show me by
all the different file system you can pick
from where is it set
don't just lay out to SF describe that's new
load this cloud from acceptance for file
that's new I don't remember those
I can missing some options here yeah here we
go so generic
so changed a little bit rated memory say it
different if you need a bail I think you
could control see out of here if you get
scared you know if you if you accidentally
did Dave SDA it would be a bad thing but
these days your main drives probably going
to be in Via me so pretty clear that you're
not going to be working on that top of the
beautiful flag you need to turn a beautiful
flag on if you're going to make a bootable
in NBR and this is what's going to be our
Taco Bell
I mean yeah this works for bac2
delete a partition list of free partitions
Listen to Partition types add a new petition
for partition table changes verify the
partition table so we're partitioning disk
using command line you can probably use it
as a graphic tool for doing this
I forget the name of it gparted I know it
must look at see what your part is I don't
you can't read you part of cuz I don't have
Graphics that's right once again command
line for the rescue so let's list all the
predictions are they are so here's all the
different partition types and any one of
these partitions can be made it which is
really cool because you can actually
stimulate I grabbing a disc from somebody
else and installing it that way we're not
going to that we're going to stick with easy
stuff you got that Windows 95 a 32A I asked
fat16 got these are old Us in here now
did they had butterface Rufus got everyone
that was huge
I look they have like hexadecimal numbers
now because they got
there's a bunch of new ones I haven't I
haven't seen before
yeah this is much anyways I'm kind of its
kind of fun because I haven't used it in a
long time
so I'm going to go up here and look at some
of the other ones I have Xanax extended
Lenox and Lenox Swap this is pretty much the
standard where free to pick
I think when he said his EXT2 it'll it'll
default to the right thing and I'll do some
the next one but if you wanted to change it
where are using virtual box from vagrant
you definitely definitely want virtualbox
and vagrant then or you can use live Birds
he's delivered for that too but I'm sitting
sitting at volumes and liver and chemo is
totally different than River box so I use
virtualbox without the graphics and that's
what I'm doing right now
XT XT 2 3 yeah I used to be better if I
don't see better on here did you see it
I'm trying I'm trying to see if I'm trying
to see if they added it as one of the
Sanders ones that you can add you know
I don't see it I see if my
maybe as a secret name hfss is Mac this is
the Mac 1
NTFS it is if you the only time you ever
have to do this is if you wanted to create a
disc volume that could be loaded into
Windows without a problem as well and then
you can plug it into Windows or or when
GFS I haven't looked at the fs at all I
heard good things but I haven't again I
haven't been in this low-level in a while so
I go back and forth between low-level and
yeah between low-level and yellow old school
stuff
Advanced VMware View FS vmfs that's
interesting I can put it on there
a bar with Arch that's pretty common I sent
Beauty
GSL I don't see it I don't see it under the
standard here
what is what is the is it is it listen after
school or is it to New 4 ft ask and I wonder
btrfs I don't see it
yeah I don't see it here I don't see this in
a list
yeah I would never use better if that's
anything serious it really no need to
but if it says it's rebuilding backups
that's what that's why people love it until
it doesn't work
I could do a logical volume manager so they
have it in this case you don't want that
this case I just want raw disc because I
just want to fill it and and tested and
stuff so I want to test out a different
volume
so anyway we can we can pick out those
things
yeah if you have been experienced is fine I
don't deal with this every day most
beginners wouldn't want him so really all we
want to do here if you want to create a new
Partition right so you can press M to figure
out how to do that again if you need to and
we're going to listen let's listen to free
unpartition space it's always fun capital F
so this this is all the free sectors and
they're listed in blocks which 512 B and as
I understand it blocks used to make up you
know
different sections of the disc but that's a
different thing now I know why they've been
measuring it if I told B for a very long
time
sectors of 1512 by
so start and end so this is
right now
the amount free is 9 MB so they must have
written some stuff at the beginning of the
disk partition and so it's left out some
stuff for us
it's in the phone previously I think it is
to you that your first I've heard about that
one too
so we we we are going to make a new a new
position so if you get afraid you don't
remember what it is going to go. I do this
already so you like my thing is if you
screwed up you didn't break anything it's
just a file yeah because it's virtual it's
just a file that's what in the files acting
as if it's a disk drive and so if you screw
it up you just redo it
I can't tell you I've said that many times
already tonight and overstayed how cool that
is so the partition table this is the scary
command this is a command that when you to a
p it actually writes it to the partition
table and from that moment on that disk is
you committed a verify print information
about a partition add a new Partition so
let's do a new one and we're going to make a
new primary petition
honest this cuz it's a raw device me to call
British number one and we're going to use
all of the disc
I have four sectors and beginning the last
sector is the end if you wanted to chop the
disc up you could do that now we don't
really need to do that because we just could
add a new device in vagra right if you if
you'd only reason you never want to chop up
an existing physical hard drive is if it was
an existing physical aren't ripe if it if
you're doing virtualization you can read
signs your hard drives for those devices get
attached virtually to your answer the
controller and then to your machine your
virtual machine is so you can size that hard
drive by by pretending to change their
physical size instead of
instead of having to chop them up dealing
with a chopped-up partition unless you
really really have to do that is not fun
usually is when I accepted a false nail to
get really into this if you ever make your
own artifices I mean Arch if you ever want
to you know get into the down-and-dirty
suffused into or Arch and building earlier
Lennox and scratching to get really into
this down and dirty detail but right now I
just want to add a new one so it's going to
hit enter create a new Partition one of type
Lennox of size 9 men
and and now we need to print it so for
pushpe a prince it was a type of person to a
110 W is right sorry I love you is right.
He's the dangerous one of these W and it
doesn't warn you it just does it so now we
have a new Partition Deb s t b h d d
chopping matters yeah I think you're
probably right if you're doing if using
actual physical drives course nothing about
it at partitioning isn't important thing to
understand is that you can pretend to have
an actual thing and end partition it up the
way you want it takes care of the primary
disc for you automatically so you don't have
to do that but yeah and there's a number of
things you can try you can actually try to
do a dual boot that be kind of fun actually
any kind of fun to play with and see if you
can make a machine to dual boot in machine
from drugs for virtualbox and have it prompt
you out and grab that fast I mean I have it
from you and grab to do something
have you weird and be funny and weird at the
same time anyway just cuz you want a bunch
of machines ice Nefertiti learning how to
install Linux it's it's not for that if you
want to do that just get yourself an old
machine and just practice reimaging it
constantly and dealing with the BIOS and
stuff because those are things you have to
understand if you want to install your own
mini my name is a plug for this is, coming
up on a long-term calendar we're going to
talk about all the stuff in great detail
during the infrastructure engineering boost
I'm sorry that's only 6 weeks of boost but
we're definitely going to talk about how to
install Linux on Hardware how to provision
stuff in Virtual machines what's
virtualization with containerization how
should you run your own home lab how to
setup your own net working at home all day
at the basics Westrate 5 that kind of thing
all the basics of just an infrastructure
with regard to Lenox and then that can kind
of
build on your knowledge of the command line
you learn for the boots everything so that's
that's the goal anyway hey how's it going to
bust your chops and I mean I'm going to
that's my goal and that's my goal I can't
promise I'm going to be able to make it but
that's that's my goal right now so so here
we've got a new a new thing now if we do
Ellis be okay now it'll look different so
now we have we have our SD be about a
primary disc of a device that's what this is
and two devices to this device's volume so
everyone called and universities this this
one is using Lan so that's the logical
volume manager which allows you to do some
fancy stuff with this by allocating extra
long story short allows you to resize a disk
it's already been created he didn't have
that you have to destroy the whole disk and
make a new one or get you some fancy tool
that lets you shrink it
so now we have a 9 MB partition called part
at has no Mount Point currently because and
that means we can't do anything with it it's
not melted is not is no way to access it
right soon so now we have to add up or did
you know the reason I'm going through this
is because these are steps that I definitely
am going to want a script and I don't
underst ripped it up to ask for so I mean it
would be silly to do so so I need to I need
to like think about that for a second
because I need to strip that but let's go
through and do the mail Point process and
then we'll come back and see what how much
of the stuff could be could be scripted
alright so first things first
all right let's go out to wait what's up
all right I do see this is same
we need to mount it so we could just get
really cheap and dirty and make him out
point so make make directory why it's been
so long since I've done this and I call NFS
it doesn't matter what you calling
and if that's stuff is generally mounted
stuff generally goes in / I meant a sentence
using t o p t doesn't matter
this is going to be hard though because
I know I know I don't know how this is going
to
and it's going to work at 3 or not we're
going to find out so the old school way of
doing this it's just too basic mount it
because it's a really easy Mount we can
assume all of the false I think it's going
to ring mount a read-only so we're going to
try it so we're going to mount Dev
SS db-21 on m n t n f s
and Larry can do that course
I got to spend so long people can laugh at
me all the time and I cannot remember my
commands wrong if this site bad superblock
icv missing code page
I'm doing it backwards that's super block I
don't think I can do this
am I doing that made it wrong I got a bad
superblock
how do I got to do to get backwards I think
I might have done it backwards
is CB1 how I did
yeah I'm doing it wrong so we need to figure
out how to do this I know it can be done I'm
just doing it wrong
and see her locked it's good it's okay for
me to figure out again
Mount CB 1
Integrity of this type how's it going at
this time
I don't think it's it's allowing me to do
the defaults having a read up on it
mounting new Drive
I wonder if it's because I have to do it
over so I have to make it a one of the one
of the Virtual Drive types
I think I might have to make it one of the
Virtual Drive types
yeah I think I do I think I might have to I
think I might have to use one of the lever
to file systems from VMware
Tennessee a we didn't have to squeeze it
already
can you change display switch off this guy.
Compatibility mode
preposition
I'm pretty sure I should be pretty someone
help me get in and we did that already
I don't think it needs a boot sector has it
I shouldn't have fish it needed she needed
me or anything because it's not booting it's
like why isn't love a supermarket
fingerless person makes me selfish crazy
like spouses to melt Point yeah oh we forgot
to format it
I just worry about it I totally forgot to
format it
yam we need this that's what this is
right
it was $60 at the label on the kitchen
device this is also going to mount it I
think
yeah this is normally this is cool to do
this by hand because I've gotten so soft in
this shit this stuff is is this is all stuff
that is done automatically by so many
systems this is why people like Arch because
our forces them to learn all these
forces and you learn all these like hard
things I'm at Lenox and remember how to do
them then like I don't need to build my own
computer and I'm fine thank you going to get
busy coding and doing other stuff
all right so we are creating a file system
on
overhead press likes to put his desperation
to have any just installed it's visible
how to create a false assumption is to make
issues that I make it fast I can text you
for now this is the kind of thing that we
would have to do with
where to know the the type of 64 is the kind
of file system you want on there so I mean
if she for is the standard for Lennox these
days it has journaling and everything so
it's the right way to go do an oversized
environment first absolutely I think you
know what I think that's a great
recommendation I think people should try to
install large but but one of the things you
could actually do using virtualbox
I'm pretty sure I can we got to try that I
bet I've been using just being box managed
you could actually create a volume and boot
that volume
you could probably start with a volume
and you could download an ISO image and you
can mount it using VM box and you can
actually do the installation all entirely
were actually of course that kind of thing
is you know not something that you would
want to do I don't know if you would get the
full experience though because you wouldn't
really deal with bio stuff again so if you
truly want an experience you need to get a
piece of Hardware old machine or something
like that and and do it that way because
they're just too much they're just too much
going on
all right so are we doing we are we are
creating a new brand new volume in order to
run manafest on a vagrant virtualbox
the native not virtual yeah because lazy
people are leaving quickly
yeah it doesn't have working environment
here so try to fix it or set up yeah
start with Native
yes what is the thing okay so it depends
what your goal is people ask me what your
favorite little sister on Mike all depends
on your goals if you if you want I like to
struggle through it and learn its shit ton
about Lennox and art your hardware and how
things work you know are charged into him
like that but that's not for me if you just
want something that works and if you think
of you know you want to fight about when do
managers then you know you got any kind of
user there
all right so we're going to go ahead and do
this command
which is another command I think I can do
for the command line I'm have to do this
though
and we're going to mount this on m n t n f s
sgv 1
and we need to do the one again is the first
partition of the volume the volume is stb
and let's see if that runs our our stuff
yeah now you see how it's wrote the super
blocking before I try them out and said I
have no idea there was a super block okay
well now it it knows what that is in
superblock is just a part of the file system
that's the part of the very beginning of the
following system is has what type of file
system it is so where do you mount can
figure stuff out and then you have to melt
the file system on top of a mountain point
and this isn't exactly really cool about
Linux amount Point by the way if your hacker
this is a great way to hide should you eat
what you can't hide it from other hackers or
anybody who knows anything about Lenox butt
butt to the average person you can mount
something over the top of something that's
already there so if you do that in a CD into
it they want to see that there's something
about to go over at hiding it it's kind of a
cool little trick you can do that the only
fools like really simple simple people that
are be coming in to see your stuff but it's
also be careful because
you might accidentally mount on the top of
something you didn't want to hide and all of
a sudden he's been up at skating in you
can't you can't get to it anymore so just
so just purifier that so that's why we had
to make a directory we made an empty
directory in m n t s f s s o y m n t is kind
of a standard place to put these things so
that they don't confuse people another
common place to mount would be / home so
like if we had if in fact I've considered
doing this if your head up multi user
environment and you wanted to have lots and
lots of systems that shared a home directory
it's a very very common thing in a Linux
multi-user world with to have like multiple
machines and everybody can log into any back
in the day when we used to distribute load
the load of users like thousands of users
right then we would say okay here's to 15 or
20 Union Station so you know Linux machines
and every single one of them is as / home
mounted against an NFS Drive
and so every time one of those machines
comes online it in terms of the home
directory it's identical to all the other
ones and that's where you get AT&T password
got the star in it for passwords that used
to read the information for login identity
from something called and is I don't know if
niss still use I haven't looked at it a ten
is an NFS for a very long time probably
since the 90s and then I'm kind of
revisiting this is why I'm doing it but it
usually and is NFS go together and I don't
see anybody interested in NIS lately and see
me talking about but there's nothing but
these are locking systems are not a thing
anymore it's not a thing anymore everybody's
got their own container don't need a multi
user login system made it back in the day
that was my mission only because we used to
melt / home on all of those machines and
then every single user has the same user ID
and when they would come out of the system
and they didn't care or what
machine was right because they're home
directory was the same no matter what
machine they attached to an end that's
that's still think so I do want to look at
identity management in using ldap some the
modern techniques are out there to create
like a jump box for multiple users to go
into your kubernetes cluster or something
like that but I don't I'm not going to focus
on that right now right now I just want to
focus on getting my manifest up if we did
this right then do you have should show that
we now have a mounted partition when we
haven't met her yet week we have the ability
to mount it but we haven't found any yet we
probably have an entry in the in the in the
we have an FSM entry we should probably have
an entry in the fs have entry now for
amenti we don't yet we don't have an issue
here we might have to add one
this is what tells you to melt things by
default right
all the stuff I'm doing by the way is stuff
that can be added automatically you so I'm
just going through the amount that commands
so just remind myself so let's make a lemon
tea
n f s I should it should melt now
I hope stb-1 m n t
Anna Faris
cerium all right yay now we do if we get our
a CB and it's 3% filled at 3% filled
it's already 3% filled MB in it and it's
already 3% filled what the hell is in there
we're going to go in there and look
I was just lost and found so it snowed is it
pretty out there
oh my God we got this wonderful snowy
Wonderland going on I should go to go film
it so this is something that is a good
memory you see how it says lost and found in
there not sorry no you're in a root of a
volume
can I do gets lost
and I know there's a file or directory or
some anything that can be written inside of
a disc if
so yeah if you go
there's anything you're lost and found
that's a 90 days been disconnected just be a
bad idea to put stuff in this either butbut
that's cool because there's only a lost and
found at the root of a volume that's the
only place it exists and it's I think it's
only a n e x t 4
we are good to go we are ready to head to
melt this and make it into an interface
export what you can do and then we want to
figure out how to automate these steps that
we just did so let me add these notes here
so we have it to do here to do
fdisk to
create a Tab S T B
1 partition then we need to do to do we need
to format it at the crater partition table
and then you have to format the partition
know I could have split up the thing to
multiple pieces that I would have run fdisk
on every one of them right format
format that partition with was it
it was Aspen make a mess yeah
create a mount point m n t n f s
i mean we can see shared instead of benefits
I see that what's a shared
is it is there a sugar Victory by default
it's not answer
yeah
any we could we can mount it at Route so we
can manage / whatever so that everybody can
go on to that file system right
that's a lot of people will will do it as a
still make an S drive right let's do that
I'm going to that yeah I'm going to mount it
as a test drive
Sasha is so if you want to go in there just
going to slash S
we have such as we have a slash you for the
users
different Mount points so I'm going to do
that I'm going to do
no in my case we're going to mount it and
we're going to exporting so and then that
would be the last thing right
I forgot to Perdition yeah and to do and
then we need to export
/ s and and then we need to
and we need to wait so it's all these are
like
Jose if control
then right and I'm going to put else
to do mounts / S I hope that it does the
control stuff first because it tries to
asynchronously provision all of these
systems the same time we can have problem
right because it's going to try
it is ever going to try to do them
and and having problems so Mount exported s
from control
else we have a worker yeah
all right so I'm going to do the steps here
I'm being like really were both about all
this because I kind of want to remember it
the boy
what are we got
alright so let's try to try the NFL Mount
extension right here cuz we did all these
other steps listed out so
I know we just need to added to the export
next Sports file but I want to review how to
do that
Monica reputation on their having tested
making anything here now
the directory permissions on this a route so
at some point you might want to change that
and the default for expertise read-only in
NFS so we want to look at that to we're not
really going to care about this because
everything is going to be we're already
coordinating the user ID to cross them
across all the system to every is tar and
somebody's been tarred with a given user ID
and you don't have things ready and
assisting me what I'm talking about
so yeah
I just go ahead and look at this I say
Touch file I'm sure we can here is something
all right so you know it we know that you
can do stuff with it right and fill it out
back because I really fill it up right now
and see what all kinds it must have a break
so that's what we're not actually bench with
you let's disconnect exit do we need to set
up for export first so there's the
formatting thing
I'm out just position switch is on the way
to reading someone reading
announce a mounting
do you have to confess to a menu for finish
this is the one we were doing
god dammit
all right so add the document I'm heading to
the read me here
any of my reference material I'm adding here
but I'm going to remove this from the
tutorial Castle you can go look up your own
okay
all right Cisco Zack guy and we need to go
look up how to export
there we go cook an FS server configuration
right at 7 p.m. of the same make directory
so we had to make a directory for the mount
Point hey how's it going doctor doctor
Marcus Rush
we're going to do this and I'm going to edit
a text to exports we can do this one command
line but we're going to do this part and
face I forgot to add the bloodline is so it
says I want to export it to this specific IP
only
we don't want to do that though we just want
to export it to the entire network which is
fine we probably have to use a kind of a
more wide-ranging thing here
until I find request yes
I think we disable the firewall permanently
but I'm going to be fine with that
so let's add it to exports
export / s
2 local area network
you can export to just a specific machine or
just the network
so how's it going oh my God
variables awesome
very awesome so I missed your call. And it
says creative campus directory to that STX
Sports
XX Sports
now this is the one of the files and you can
get really fucked in if if you do not also
need to make sure your suit over there to
get hungry or ask you where your roots are
fine but you cannot have any extra spaces in
this file it is it will croak and die
so any amount we can line up fast space I
know we need the IP
we're not going to read squash
read why it right we want sink on all this
stuff but we need to change the stuff you
need to change it to our
to our and other examples all these choices
are documented in in here you can go to go
to the man page for exports
what side is what called
so we're going to go down here service start
the rpcbind a minute and if a server and his
order to start remind me to check the status
okay so we have got to go look at what goes
in the export file because
and if SX4 to local network I want to look
up the network listing for the side I can
look it up but hey I asked blank screen
X-Ring in FS this is our generation oh no
this is Linux practical example sex wearing
a fisher's to Linux
experts share to single hose to all ho Sia.
There we go so we need to figure out what
are our ranges
I kind of I don't know if it's going to be a
sec
I think this is our first reason to actually
list the the network range in our vagrant
creation so that we have a consistent IP it
doesn't just guess cuz I know we don't know
what IP ranges is going to be as far as I
know
and it's kind of a vagrant thing
I think I'm going to search for something
else on this I'm going to say what is the
default IP network range for vagrant I think
it's probably worth that explicitly putting
us in our bigger and file
see how to change speaker to phone network
ragonese Levert we going to use
networking vagrants go up here
configure forward port forward a meeting
with that we want the range is what we want
purple rain is a thing but when I'm going to
do that right now so right now we're going
to go look
and see the private Network there we go
here we have Network IP
so here is the IP address of the VM replace
it with your own if he shouldn't be able to
take effect if you want to say Pedro is it
automatically bhcp modify the private
Network definition by this I think this is a
default random IP address to be a sign of
the end in order to find out if either of
you need to SSH into the various Nations and
do I become in the public network
an impeller is never going to be able to be
the same network as your host machine East
Fillmore receive its own IP address that's
because we're using bridge for that so
we don't want you to be actually want to set
the private Network
they want to be able to set the range of
IEPs
and I don't think I'm be done I think it
just I just picked a random network ID from
your internal localhost
at me we can probably check right now just
by looking let's go look so if we go on to
vagrants SSH into SSH into control
how's it going to risk a risk risk ex-wife
so IPA we're going to go check it out
so so here we have ETA is 0
this is on a 10. Network 10.0.2 I wonder if
it's always 10.0.2
your name I don't know that it is we're
going to find out
because we can't we can't export it until we
know that IP range now I could go under the
control box
but I think in order to mounted from the
workers were going to have to be able to
point at it
so
all right
Echo rpcbind
I don't know how to pick to stay at the
apartment work so that let's just figure
that out
I don't either. We're probably in for
another one we don't need it for today
what LOL
we can do anything on. Local amighetti's of
Ahi for the naming
yeah we will actually give it a name
oh my God
localhost look in the main localhost look in
the main it didn't it didn't give it
anything
oh yes it did control
I mean this isn't this isn't no sense for
the network at all
so what are we got we have is there any nice
or 0
I don't know I try to figure out how we can
do this mapping on a vagrant normally in an
environment you know exactly what your IP
stuff is we have to scrape this based on how
big are build something so that makes it a
bit trickier and not too bad but
I'm pretty sure that we can do
just a generic
this is the stuff I got to do is like a big
No-No that's why I'm driving super
interested you know
see here see on the client you need to do a
mountain need to be able to provide the IP
so if we don't give it an IP or we don't
mean to pull up a DNS server which is
another thing you know what
I mean it might be worth doing a DNS server
all by ourselves on one of these things it
might be worth having a vagrant that
Provisions a DNS server
this because if you if you can add that work
to this work and then we have a DNS server
we can actually assign the Eyed Peas to the
DNS server as well and make the whole thing
like virtualize but but I don't know if I
like it or no
yeah this is this is mounting it without
permission is eccentrics or so
this is some restarting feser blah blah blah
yeah I don't have to know I don't think
yes yours is there's the path and there's a
hose and there's options
I think the host can be a wildcard though
and then I would never haveand I would never
have used a while car before that's why I'm
a sign of possible Spider-Man PowerPoint and
if it's not recommend you first read it or
even if that's the difference between blah
so this year as a single hose
to a single client is in a festival to
exercise to get to refresh to share block no
options for back of bus I just bought
hey I'm in a can we get this morning
I'll get the wondering if we do it with the
sink thing
I swear it's sure to all hose there it is
it's a star alright that's what we want
that's what we want all right so that's like
the every fucking hoe something out where
this is really dangerous this is not
something you would do this is not something
you would normally do know it's like
but we're going to do it oh let me some Elsa
got open
who else has got an open to having also been
somewhere else bad me wait where are we for
are we go tonight so yeah this is there
anywhere to get over there okay so let's
change this to Star and we wanted to read
right we wanted to be a synchronous this
means two people can write to the same file
at the same time which is super dangerous
but it's no more dangerous than Unix already
allows so you know we don't want to risk
washing anything I think we could just do we
want to try 10:00 and probably a sink I need
a sink is a default you have to look at all
these options and I just know that we'd ride
is the one I want and I wanted to be a sink
I don't want to be able to people to go
right to the thing at the same time I have a
conflict at this probably considerations
there if you have a trailing space this
won't work
is this will not work export FS that's hard
to refresh it now
if I think we have to turn on and if s let
me see
systemctl are PC Vines
I whoops status
all right so obviously but he's not running
we need to have that run and then we have to
run n f s
this is what I can't figure out where does
an FS come from I think I installed it wrong
sudu now I see wrapped install
Anna Faris is a local server colonel
sir or something that we got to see him of
course
I forgot how to install it I supposed to be
at fault
somebody was telling me that yesterday
alright so
okay so so so so so we need to we missing
some installs here
we are still in effect utils rpcbind was
already on there
install n f s all red head
somebody said it came by default and I don't
see it
sonfs you tells you did that
includes I need to build your nfsr alright
well so why is it running
or if it's serious to that but nobody nobody
shown
and if that's your squash
I don't need the Powerball rules inside if
it's a city.
What are the mount why is Manifest already
I mean
I guess you don't need her to see behind we
have everything but I thing but I don't
understand
hey I guess it's built in it maybe maybe
supposed to the colonel I don't know how to
sing to the service
I'm seeing is turn off though so pseudo
systemctl enable dash dash now rpcbind
alright so let's go
oh my God
go away
the Citadel says 50
systemctl NFL he's not a thing so when will
you know we need to do
we need to do a table by India
RPC mine are busy buying is a sub service of
it was made back in a time when we knew that
there was to be a limited number of ports
and four different services so are perceived
as a way to connect to Lennox in Unix and
decide and negotiate what port you're going
to communicate on from that point on
rather than have a lockdown Port that you
had to use every time getting around this
port issue is been completely address by
kubernetes now so you don't see a lot of
stuff that uses our PC invented it does but
not this RBC not to like the Lennox RPC it
was it was designed for a different problem
where we had one server that was going to
deal with like multiple different
applications and services business people
write their applications and services to use
RPC and instead of saying oh I'm going to
run on this specific configure port in the
whole architecture in it has changed and
doesn't use this too much anymore that stuff
is all dealt with by containerization and
you know virtualized container networks that
we seen caretti's the main reasons he really
needs is a big thing is because a ton of
machines can have the same exact
configuration the same port listeners and
everything and it just works because of the
network routing
so in one sense it's a large work around $4
BC stuff so if we do this now we can say
we should be able to say well it should be
running so let's let's go look
on the status rpcbind I guess rbc's the only
service this thing right now
yep and so we should be able
how to connect in from another service
vagrants worker
oops SSH worker one
and not found or the filling out the dash up
there we go so
here we go now we can actually Mount from
here
we should be able to mount it I should be
able to see do make directory / s
and Studio was just used to do as soon as
and we should be able to mount just using
remote
what are the IP is up here and this is the
other thing we're going to figure out if
this is going to have to have a specific IP
this is this is what this can get tricky for
vagrant because we need to know the IP of
the thing we're going to mount right
and I that server has to have a specific
I don't know how we're going to be able to
get around that honestly I don't I don't
think probably will be able to get around it
so here's here it is on the network though
worked out so that we could say Mount this
I think it's colon slash / S2 / ass
it's going to try to talk to it I might have
that came out wrong
mount dashti
Medina Fisher director of the climate she's
at Mount st.joe its type is in a Fest
Matt dasht-e this was an ef-s eventually
and I can't talk to him I think it might be
the firewalls on
wait did I start work now she can see it
okay
ssage I want to see if we get a full
connection to it
yes
unless I don't know if that's right it needs
to be using the I don't want to sell puppy
and Corruption right now or keep pears for
that I'm at a few but I can't accept
password
so let me get let me get this so
write the number that we have our share
and the remote share and then you have the
local share right
I know what I think it is I think I have to
do I know what it is okay yeah I have I'm
pretty sure at the mount the same thing m n
t n f s just like a woman on the other
system right
I don't know it could be that this not
answering they are PC things not answering I
don't know how to check to see if rfs's up
so that's that's a hard thing to do that I
don't understand
it should I should work though
so let's do this I think there's a dad-to-be
wish there were
weather is nice program not registered the
connection was refused
so the NFL server is not answering
that's the problem program not registered
oh oh okay so are PC is yes they are piece
eating is running but the NFL software is
not started and I don't know how to start
unifest services on here
and said everything is in an FS is it NFS
client
loaded active and if it's Client Services
for the men FS
I'm active mounted Mountain FS loaded active
mounted
are those services are PC services
Mountain FS unattractive
we need to figure this part out so
communication from everything else is there
alright so let's see
distance ATL
they need a different it's not it's not
called the NFL's service anymore so I don't
know how to
how to find that
all right we've got
I still have our PC stuff
is your progress it seems like they moved it
internally but it acted mounted
interesting I don't know where they moved it
when you search for this
where is an FS server in redhat 8
our vision for the speaker up nfsr Alyssa.
Rpcc
no it's not there so I'm trying to say it's
not there it hasn't been in since installed
so it's an FS server Dash service
it's not just an FS yeah here we go all
right so systemctl
enable dash dash now NFS server
nice all right and let's do our rep in fs
and boom Okay so
all right I need to put some information in
my notes Here Zedd create
start an FS and our PC
on red hat Huron red hat I need to take
notes on this right so
all right so cuz it's so IFS
runs as nrpc as server service
therefore to check for it use the r PC
info command
I mean
if it isn't there in means it hasn't been
installed
or needs to be enabled
70 pseudo
yum that's why I install nfsu tills
okay so and then whatever you need to do
then we need to do Studio system
any more stashed now rpcbind
and an FS server
all right that's some good notes have to be
able to pull those notes up later quickly
I have a feeling that we're going to be
going
yeah I'm that we might not even have to do
anything and if this is pretty robust and
wait at figuring stuff out so like
tell us the straight here so
write the connection was finally free refuse
RPM program not registered let's just try it
again
for my profile I think it's because we don't
have the client installed
yeah I don't think we do
and what you're doing yeah we are still in a
fist utils so
how can I get the client over here issue it
should be working what's the deal
let's try it for a not registered Rock
princess versions versus incision 9th and
25th
I have her a try we have to redo our export
I think of you
o x nope
haha I'm so forgetful but it's definitely
running
it's only running and it's listening to
everything
hundred so far we don't have 50 on here
anyway
I have a disabled we didn't we didn't
disable of firewalls know we didn't
we didn't get this is new I disable the fire
was on the other on the other instance I was
going I met that's in yeah
so Farwell Damon
turn off
if only for a while on this to doesn't seem
like it's listening on the right port
this all figured out as the navel
I receive our diversity to get S call him I
can figure it out if it's where you can find
for your spouse
creams for your fish are we did that we did
this we in this a firm's issue
yeah I could be they could be from Joshua's
that soup or 2727 if I will yeah absolutely
can do that I don't want to right now
did I do now
you didn't like that I just right now I
don't I don't want to fuck with ports
there's definitely instructions on how to do
the poor thing so we should do the poor
thing properly to learn it in the long term
but I think I want to make sure the
permissions are fine
an ml mount FS
yeah we need to make this is also really
dangerous
but we need to turn me to open the
permissions up on that
equation for a furnace in this guy will send
you all the information to direct you to the
NFL share folder
yep
I don't know if I should send a picture cuz
I don't think I figured out of shown I think
this might be stopping you from getting
mounted to the truth
I didn't do any for sure but I think we
should do this
Mount n f s
and restore nfsu tools
yeah I would not have thought you that maybe
that's what I need to do system
sm-6 yell
utils there's utils answer and mountie
holyshit
Port map not working
it is Sir I'm going to need to restart RP
see buy into
AA promises it can't connect to it so it's
it's not seeing the running service
Griffin ephessus there it's listening Nets
stats
there is definitely listening but it's not
connecting could be the outbound firewall I
don't know I mean
give me the IP is wrong let's try that
it's soon to not 15 on 24 so that's huge
should be fine
any Wheat we know because we pinged a thing
Paint n. 0. 2. 15
penis is up everything's up SOC on the fire
report to me and I can't hear
how's it going
how far is it how are you I see services
NFS is 2049 Okay so
and see
nc-20 49 oh
have a good that's not good
I am app I am map
install
I have a feeling it's not something's
blocking it you have the wrong IP or
and this is funny cuz he's are all Hacker
techniques
yeah it's it's listening rpcbind it's just
not listening
for some reason the NFL stuff not loosening
the server. Now I know it's supposed to go
to that
that's PA
now we could do
I mean the 2049 to delegate it to that so
that's everything always confuses the issue
when you're when you're dealing with for
scanning and it's closed it says
Alex
so I'm not sure if that's because every
piece of you normally our PC is fine Fort
map
irbc is supposed to delegate the incoming
forced to do so and if x is supposed to go
to our PC and say hey what part do I need
and then it delegated to the porch and
that's why we're not showing that particular
part is listening even though it is
listening so
so I'm missing something simple here I don't
know what it is it's almost like an FS
server is not running in the way it needs to
be
I miss you something simple something simple
anime sink
export I didn't do a RV
I did not use a army list for that
I just want a fast exporting
manifest
the shoe Mill do it
so close we're getting their connection
refused
how can I getting connection refused
format Carrie query we train our Police
Department registered
it seems like the RPC it seem like our PC
does not know about the NFL service
that's that's what it seems like to me and I
did I miss something I obviously missed
something
to me it seems like our PC does not know how
do you look at all the RPC stuff I forgot
I meet with rpcbind has an offense in here
oh whoops can when it when is it do info
it says there's the Manifest running already
right
so I don't know what's really going on here
that's if it was also there should be a
short a short stance for exporting all
directories V
I asked for the fuss
Sr Mount so they sing til I hide try to
start Port map for UPS on
should I be on already I know he's really
surprised
I thought perhaps your PC service all right
I think they renamed it I think it's hard to
see my now I don't know I don't know
okay the final step in for your service a
lot of his servers through the fire on
sentiments ate the services are and if it's
something by Tenth Mountain D I have not
been restarting mountie though
this is a really great document do I got to
add this to my roommate
yeah
I'll reload I don't know firewall that might
my impression is that fart
my precious the firewall is still getting in
the way but
it doesn't seem to be the case there is no
firewall Damon running at all I killed it
inactive dead
tell her if I was here at 6.
I mean I fell asleep and get you some other
poor other
give me a dang it might not hurt but I don't
think that's it I really don't
if his client is something wrong with your
clan ankle tools one of that's it
I've never put those on before
and if is common Havasu till zarfoss medical
tools
just put them outside of fishers in the show
Malcolm and
on the server oh hey there's a good ping
let's do that
show Mount I didn't know you could do
external are you do that
exported on 10.
Show mounts Dashie but then you go aren't
you program at register
yeah that means
let's go to that are specificallylet's go to
that are specifically
animal
krain corner clamp I can't wait to get your
extra client over there.
Very good I'm taking Kyle fucking rvcc
Weber rotisserie
nothing there come on baby
I don't think something is not connected
between RPC and n f s
are busy buying service got started yes if
any of that
does every Sea by need to be on the client
as well and doesn't write
I think it might be I mean it couldn't be
there
are is active it's running it's listening
it does need to be rebooted mrpc info has a
Nifty has an offense in here so far so good
right
search orpc info yeah
it's definitely listening
are busy but I'm glad I'm looking at the
stuff I remember having to debug this before
are Sylvania got it
limcee dead men it's the same thing
or Superuser I mean it could be this is
Superuser this doing it you know
it could be the ACL things it could be
something to these heels and she can you
denied
it could be I mean it could be a mission
such as this being shown in something
different right
mount mount is running to
I do not need to be restarted every time I
don't think it does
FS melty and lock a manager
s e n f s a c l is running to it that makes
me think that there's an an ACL thing that's
not installed
you know what I mean
I'm going to try this I'm going to try to
install this cuz I don't think that's on the
client
in my case so
install
yeah there's no ACL tools I have a feeling
it's not authorizing I mean it could be that
but I'm not register this so weird I guess
not
help for I'm not registering a just keep
saying the RPC failures are or unusual
they're unusually cuz that means it is
talking to our PC and then
it's making it on PC connection in our PC
say hey there's no one at Fest over here and
I mean
I almost think I should take it down the
services in order
because I started rpcbind before I
startedstarted an FS server
I bet you if I start an FS server first and
then start PC by and it might be better off
what do you think let's try that it can't
hurt so system cgl
since I'm absolutely yeah and I can paint it
and talk to it and everything yeah that's
something I thought that wouldn't make me an
issue
and whips if it's there
I mean I can assist you and everything so
the RPC Services connecting this message
that message is being generated from
the server I want to say this is actually
the RPC is making or PC connection in the
RPC server is telling from the client I
don't have a service called NFS which means
it somehow it doesn't see it even though our
prpc info says it's right there
so do you mean because it's it says it's
there so
Imma Try Something system cclr PC info
rpcbind stop
stop halt whatever
alright so
and I'm going to stop and Fs you so sorry
star actually
let's restart now the NFL server
I think that might be it actually and then
let's restart rpcbind
and I don't think we have to
I I don't think we have to restart buying
the
Absolute Towing it
it's just it's not going to I don't stop
it's like really freaking confusing
I'm out going wrong I live on Canal Road
all right so so so so it's like I'm hacking
into an FS but now I'm like motivated
I don't think why do we need nfsu2 Hills
we already have an official seals on the
clients so that's not a thing but I don't
even see why he would need that I don't
if it's already
tell me the acsi keeps him vacation where to
read with that error message means
this is a very hard thing to find cuz people
don't have our PC Services is really old
it's really really hard to search for the
ship because it's ancient knowledge
her up she sure acted like his Services
cream crust
positive ways RC versus Wade as is nice
that's pretty good to add
all right so I don't know I don't know if I
figure I got to start this all over again
so from like Step 1
I want to say that I I think that order in
which we booted
the we started up to Services is still
affecting it but I have no indication of
that otherwise I shall Mount is failing III
like
here's exactly what we tried to do and it's
not able to connect
and yeah we can't so you can see it
wait we haven't we haven't we haven't
directory right as long as that's not their
decisions that somebody is
Ella stay right there
McGinnis I don't think it's a permissions
issue of such as running is route and
I mean unless that's the wrong machine that
mean that's the only other possibility
let's try something so for guitar vagrant
SSH
IPA so
all right so we have we we wait
wait what how many zombie praying
and to make any sense I might have the wrong
IP number
it doesn't make any sense cuz we had map
that has a seizure
I've been seeing for SP-10 for the recorder
I don't know about AR-15 for it I didn't
know it was remote command I haven't used it
before
I know it looks like they're all the same IP
is like how the fuck is it doing that it's
impossible for them to have the same IP
that's impossible
now that you're right so
I'm have two deployments Bridge Network make
any sense though
because they're supposed to all be on their
same network does that mean vagrants not
putting them on the same network
it's fucking insane what's a quick command
to get the exact IP of the system on a th20
I just grabbed find out I guess
I see that
I batdr is that the one yeah I can't
remember
at last what I am doing right now eight is
too afraid to hear I'm pretty sure
cell they all have the same IP holyshit
that is blowing my mind how the fuck do they
have the same IP does that mean every single
one of them is knotted
oh my God they all are every one of them is
added
new Z8 do these easy recipe
these used to people they should be getting
that they're supposed to use the ACP from
vagrant
well that explains it I mean we least found
the problem
and that's definitely the problem is there's
no doubt there's a problem
I mean that's that's crazy yeah
what time do I check what their JCPenney
dresses over there so she if they have
Lisa's or whatever
what is it that the thing it doesn't the
thing that totally confuses me is
that means every one of them
there's no way you could get the same IP
there's no easy way
this is this is important I really have to
understand that working with Vigor and
because this is a we're going to be using
they going to test
using a drone to test networking so
yeah and there is no networking
configuration it's just a default right
so so yeah I thought I was going to be able
to just ignore this
but clearly we can't we're going to have to
set our own private Network and then have
everything beyond that work and
inside of yam well we were just in one you
talked about making a new one
Aries prime number guess what I'm saying it
did 10. Network is this is the private
Network right
that's what I understand because okay I'm
snow
there is no other network
this is very confusing to me
I didn't think two two two systems could
exist the same IP address without causing a
serious problem
that works for me Cinemark in Yosemite
yeah
no these are all these are all internal and
these are all on these are on the plate of
Naperville
yeah they're they're all deployed with
vagrant so they all get
whatever you know what let's go look that's
actually open virtualbox in and look at it
graphically so here they are these get a
vision automatically approve a green right
do they have the same give me address I
don't know that's what we're trying to
figure out so
here we go out network adapter Nat
so this is this is what I think has happened
I think each one of these has has an
attitude connection is all getting shared
and we probably offer so I know I'm pretty
sure we can fix this by just sitting at
Bridge Network and be done with it but when
we do the movie provision it but I'm just
really curious
how it got this far along
attach to net Bridge Eternal Network so
now suffice it to say we're going to have to
do some more networking network setup
check with a network config which network in
fig
so the back look alike.
169 why would they have run 69 I'm in the
van right now
Etsy
there's there's Network at figures it I mean
it's Rich redhead so
back to DP
is felis currently only has a connection
with jrpc literacy
yeah I don't see anything that I recognize
here cell
I I I think I know how to fix this I think
the way to fix this is to explicitly defined
the
private Network for the vagrants
house when they're provisioned and I think
that that will do the magic to set up the
networking
which is not doing clearly now I thought for
sure it was know what was confusing to me
the most of all is that I can get to any of
these things
it knows about them it knows how to get to
them that's thethat's the that's the
confusing part
you know what when it was bringing it up at
told us what 16-16-8 network it was on
are give me a second there when we when we
did the vagrant up thing
the same same take down one of the one of
the
I think I'm one of the workers just take
that work or two so worker
reload record till now watch the output
so right that she freeze machine we can
definitely do that but it's getting is going
to give a 16-8 address
so I think I think we can use a different
address
because he sees her now to 192 yeah
static IP DHCP house ain't ya DHCP does
allocate them but they're not known to the
client
they're not they're not known to itself
that's what's confusing right and that's
that's what I'm that's why I'm confused by
two cycles through
what just going to give us a p it's going to
say there is a generous know it gives us
another one
I remember this printing out the number of
the IP address for SSH connect connections
running shell and I guess not
maybe after the Reformation I mean be with
you more the reprovision it
oh no I just created a new IP and just put a
new SSH arrest for the same worker for well
I see what it's doing
as for say
yeah it makes me want to end up my whole
119:160 network
but these are not in so they shouldn't be
getting direct eyepiece from that they
should be getting they should be getting eye
peas from this computer and using this
computer as if it had the hcp to give out
Manassas that's how I've seen that that's
What mattered what are the routes say should
we look at the routes again
annotation gateway's when I said to
they all have the same fight for you though
the side of my TV is not working can pig
yeah
right
I think two things would fix this I think if
either explicitly putting in the vagrant
file
but I'm kind of curious yeah
they they do they don't have the same
gateway then we'll know it's a different
that right oh I see where you going
okay I don't know if it's
it's so weird have the same Gateway that the
same IP address
and they have the same Mac address
they can't talk to each other that's the
problem now they can't see each other at all
they can't see each other at all that's the
problem that's why are PCS not working so I
did the crazy thing is I have my pins in
this is Asia's everything we're working
because I was just contacting myself because
the routes The Raspberries we're going to
the same one
yeah I tried to make an investment on 10.2
9:15 and I mentioned it was probably DNS
round-robin anything to one that doesn't
have it so I was either hitting worker it is
a thing we are but I don't know
Adam Statesville I know I could try that one
though I mean this is super interesting
this is actually really good to practice my
networking stuff to a bit more I've been a
while since I've done that work I do
debugging
so that's actually cool and I'm stopped what
is that when I don't use it NM State CDL
I kind of don't want to throw this away it
just yet because I really want to figure
this out
is it NM state
estate auction is that doing when I start it
say mac addresses yeah
I don't know that's what blows my mind that
I've never seen it before I've never seen
that before this is the first time
I've seen two vm's running on the same
system with the same Mac address
DNS resolver oh that's the name okay
is that easy JCPenney now
that's why I'm saying if there's a vagrant
sitting in the network that will tell it to
use the hcp and it's not doing it by default
my default it's not doing shit
oh yeah I said I said I'll try to figure out
how it's not configured from that I know
oh you think the image is fucked up you
think the image itself my baby fuck up
yeah interesting that would be a bugger in
Elma 8
are there we can check that really quick by
using like one of the extent of us like a
stream the stream thing
yeah
I need to reconfigure networking yeah well I
don't want to reconfigure networking right
now myself I mean. This is a cool exercise
but this is not necessary for what I want to
do
all right yeah
that's what I'm trying to figure out Bill
how the fuck do they get an IV with no DHCP
in a virtual machine I have no idea this is
the thing that baffles me this reason I
don't want to throw this away and try by
adding look there's case anybody just wants
to Jump Ahead there is a no. VM. Network
configuration that's missing from here than
almost everybody puts in everything and I
figured I would use the default
like the bigger box has static IP networking
yam right and
yeah I don't think central is comes with
static IP set up by default I don't think
that's a thing right
I don't think that's a thing I think it's I
think the image itself is messed up yeah
there's
if
I don't know maybe maybe it is done by
vagrant make maybe vagrant is doing it since
I didn't put anything in the networking
thing it did do any magic and so it as soon
as I want to set up a piece and it wants me
to explicitly to find the IP in the in the
vagrant file for each one
I mean that's a possibility it could be that
that it's letting me do that you know it's
like hey you didn't tell us what to do
automatically so we expect you to set up
your own IP networking
I thought vagrant works
the thing I don't understand is how this is
even on the network at all
and the only reason I'm able to SSH into the
thing is because the SSH is all
cuz the SSH is on 127 and there's some
protocol routing and they've mapped a
specific ports I sought make her do that in
that specific ports to specific machines
and that's what is bypassing a network IP
routing completely otherwise how the fuck
are you connected to it I'm afraid yeah
that's what really confuses me
so so this is serious discovery
I'm in a truck all this and try a different
image to see if it has a similar issue
and I'm using generic El Metate
what MC Lyte device modify ETA should be the
method also there why
why would I do that just to check if you
still on on the thing to try to get a
networking to work by itself that we're
doing at work he bugging I find an exciting
but it's actually not relevant to what I
want to do
yeah this is I need to do this has been a
really good reminder that I need to really
deep dive into colonel in our network
configuration and stuff like that mcla
device modify
ETA is 0 ipv4
yep
at least we're going to let you use it real
Ruby not Rouge next hop address
24 I didn't think of it as someone i p at
now
do we do we change it to used to be but then
we have to restart not working right can't
you just restart system CDL or sissy to
restart to get the how do you restart
networking these days and used to be you do
and it networking restart
and I don't know how to restart networking
I don't want to admit one and then it's 6 or
5 or whatever it is not 3 I think
do you remember
yeah
ice regulars use real Ruby not reset the
server evening networking only
yeah
I got a raise every reset it's used HTP and
we need to be able to restart the machine to
use the pull-down the networking
yeah this is some pretty interesting at work
an admin stuff
yeah they're there is I just don't know
which one it is
it is changed
Linux restart networking restart the entire
networking service
and is it the network manager
since I was a dick in his Network oh my God
that's cool that's what I used to use hasn't
changed yay
assistant seashell status Network
he felt I would be a no then you can check
the network status
nope that would be a no
I am pretty sure it's sissy t l redhat uses
nmcli
isn't it says beside for the name
and then are there we go
and I'm still I'm really hoping to join
network manager while I didn't go as a
redhead thing right
I am so I networking
train station
animeand a mother
to to do to do afar on
man that's totally cool you know I might
have to get rid of certified
I might have to if I'm going to keep doing
this red has got so many quirks to it that
it make it unique
yeah
enter the connection type
it's me. I've been tables holyshit
I just got this stuff is cuz I had the last
time that I dug down into Network managers
and stuff like that was 20 years ago
it's changed so much goddamn it's so
different seriously I have so much to catch
up on
and then you know all that all I'm
programming that I do it just takes away
from you know everything is just moving so
fast there's just so many layers in keeping
track of every fucking thing all the way
through application development and
container orchestration in Cloud
architecture and then all of the low-level
in a service changes to the system
administration that's just so fucking much
to learn as crazy as a pain in the ass yeah
I was just going to say network manager is I
don't even know networkmanager it used to be
that you added a couple of miles a year has
started your network service in the net your
and it's ripped and you're good to go but
it's totally different now and it's just
insisted he's complicated the shit out of
everything 2 so I feel like a kindergartner
looking at the stuff I do this shit like
inside and out as you know
am I not right. I'm totally Red Hat now yeah
for Enterprise for Enterprise I'm already at
yeah
I pee I know is a little air it already is
right that's what's so crazy is it I mean
it's just yeah but I mean if you're going to
act this shit then I got to know about it so
either other than ministering entering
breaking into it I want I need to know it
all
is there an attic and what did she High
feeling up and down
and I'm still right-handed Khan you should
cereal
yeah I I got a I got a back I have to back
away from
yeah I think I have to step away from this
because I just can't I can't I got to get
back to the NFL stuff I want to dive into
the networking right now but I right now the
networking is really fucked and this is a
vagrant thing so I mean we can spend all
night trying to go through Network debugging
and configuration to understand it and I'm
super interested to do that but I need to
pull myself out of this to this is what I
understand it's got to do is to post name
it's pulling down to the stuff that was
added
let me check the other worker that stuff
that was added right when we did her when we
did the nmcli command
there's no Colonel now right at the same One
external assistance from distro
I need to restart it yeah
yeah but I want to know where he's going to
pull it and she pull up from the parent do
you see piece of rubber thing
I think because the thing is this is what
I'm afraid of with an adding right is like
who's going to serve up the DHCP just going
to broadcast to the networkers and not going
to go outside of the internal Network
yeah that's right I mean I'll try a couple
of those things with you but I want to leave
this
alright so was it what was it nmcli or IPA
I'm still 25 but yeah
add some so 25 I think
you know it seriously we can spend a very
very long time
I changed the networking layer of the of the
OS
yeah Red Hats Red Hats Reds trade for
Enterprise stuff
it's not great it's it's what's useless but
that way so
if you have on a mall Hy-Vee ad
yeah I did that already they're all the same
again I mean we didn't already is Affordable
for this already
cell oh fuck I basically a parent and not a
command
and then I got 15 they have the same now
that the same either at address and the same
IP address and that that is completely out
of my realm of reality I have never seen
that before
that's what I'm trying to say they have the
same package rest I know that's what I don't
understand
I do not understand how they have the same
week we were noticing that earlier lvg no
actually won't notice that so
I don't know that's why I'm saying so fucked
up we have to figure it out
I don't know bigger bigger a couple friends
about can fix any of that. So maybe I'll
help ya there this is oh God arcade that's
fantastic let's go ahead and look at this
one
yeah this is okay so
this is really fucking weird this is what it
is this put this out there this is from a
fucking where the reason that I didn't
notice right away is I would never ever look
for the system's having in the same or a
dress
I I mean I don't even know how that thing is
fucking working
I mean that's just so unusual is really
unusual Ray Grant gives vm's same our
address and I'm going to I'm going to
document this because I have to come back to
this for the next poor Schmo who asked if
you hit this issue god dammit
coffee
oh God
should
Linus Tech tips latest Linus Tech tips at it
again
all right
thank you for finding this arcade
I'm just putting in my like I just want to
lose your legs before they scroll off it's
it's one of the advantages of having a tiny
Community I can actually keep up with the
chat and I suppose it's the strange VM world
we live in and where Mac addresses are no
longer unique
at all
everything here you can have the same
address here you can have the same address
and you we can all share Mac addresses in
this peace love and Lennox kind of world
it's fucked up
Burger you can even assigned the same IP at
Mark's address to two things and still have
them not to blow up is just remarkable to me
oh I'm not complaining I think this is
really fun actually
is really fun actually it's it's it's
blowing my real reality
it has to be Let It Be Alex tags devices to
static Mac address yeah
so this is one that says what
Baker's the same as him if actress to 2 p.m.
what is going on is this crazy it's an issue
that's created by the Box you are using sent
to a 6 bucks in the box is Vigor and file it
is it is hard coating at the base Mac used
by the Guess
pictures of certificate Magnus you can
prevent this Behavior by adding that you all
can make her file config via base Mac equals
Neil which will result in them being
auto-generated well there's like some
esoteric weird work around and vagrants that
I would never have known had it not been for
my fantastic community
yeah
there is a sense OS / Red Hat bug in the
vagrant
image that forces them to all have the same
Mac and Ivy it wasn't even that they were
getting the same IP they had the same Mac
address and therefore they are all given due
to flee the same IP because there's a
package rest
I look how come I hit this issue I this is
the Story of My Life
the Story of My Life and then people yell at
me and they say you didn't do it wrong you
like you didn't follow proper procedure to
find out all of your errors yours all over
the place can we just can we just pause for
a second and they agree that this was not my
fucking issues this time because I didn't
rush into it or some shit this is like some
random esoteric fuck shit out there that
screwed me over cuz the music redhead that
we can play
is it going to be using a redhead image
looks this place the blame where it belongs
this blame belongs in the people who
maintain the image the vagrant image that
I'm using right
so it's so
okay by the way this is not a red hat
issue it's a vagrant red hat image issue
I suspect so
it is mxp nice to know it makes me it makes
me feel good to know that I'm not fucking
going insane
the base Mac equals no
who would think that you would have to say I
don't want that I want to kill my Mac
address to write
I'm here to find all these esoteric
weird-ass shity things so that you don't
have to
yeah we're going to start all over with an
FS from scratch because
networking is a think I kind of want to tell
it what network and to use with let's just
go ahead and check out all this stuff and
start over showing
wait what wait what
I'm just killing stuff with wild abandon
RPC hey look at look at all the network
Diagnostics I just learned that I had
totally forgot about before that I'm now
where that I need to Deep dive into the hole
NM thing you know the RPC reminder that
Howard BC Services work and how they relate
to and it
and if I passed another Services user PC all
of that stuff is like been a great reminder
so
alright what are we going to do here we're
going to do yeah
they received this is my other one that I
was looking at
I am trying to simplify here cuz cuz cuz the
reasons I feel like I can get a grip on
reality again all right time to throw should
I weigh
time to throw the sheet away
oh hell yeah he kidding me
vagrant destroy this okay so first things
first
the first thing here is I would not have had
this issue had have been doing physical
machines
Heaven is a physical machines with actual
Nick's this would not have happened I would
have had other issues but not this
I wouldn't think so this is an issue that
was brought about because of her some
machines and I I want to take a moment to
just take stock of that yeah this this world
of magical virtualization provides a lot of
amazing things but it also sucks you up in
this case because if
you know that this is this entire last hour
that I just lost was because of
virtualization and I would not have lost
that our so the time one by virtualization
over here doing all the stuff with physical
devices
is in some sense also kind of paid back by
look up since for some position so you know
if you like backing away from this whole
problem address those kinds of things when
you go back make it up that I'm going to
walk away all this comes up and the first
thing I'm going to look at it to see if they
have the same address that's going to be
very interesting I'll be right back
and just it just dumb
cuz in the boxes bigger than 10 gigabytes
Elroy
it's freezing it's freezing here and they
are
I just lay down a whole new layer of snow
you like new snowfall
I think there's a way to make it not import
every time right you can use that link thing
I saw Megan setting called link something
and it keeps it from importing
can I shrink Megan primary disc fine
I thought you had to have that to have a
secondary disk obviously I was wrong
actually I think the primary just found this
is 70 GB ridiculously high thing
Ellen close app yeah you found outside
looking for
yeah I was just I actually I read briefly
about it yesterday
I'm learning way more than I want to buy
Baker probably time I go through all the
docks a l b g
maybe you should read all the documents Mi
to the fuck out I know
not right now
as a provider thing right
then provide a thing
now
well we tried I don't know if it needs to be
in a provider or not
complete I just want to eat in your in your
ear
they haven't seen my peace still Hey Joe
they have different Mac addresses though
different Mac addresses
nothing first step Lexi
car wash
prep user
back to you but we can't I mean I actually
think we can fix that by setting the network
I think if we use the vagrant network
settings don't want to try that first or do
you want to do and I'm so I do what I can
try to fix this by hand just cuz fun cuz fun
I think this is because it's their static
IPS but now we have our progresses right
so what I'm guessing is that
I don't know Bill I don't know cuz I'm brand
new to all this so we're just experimenting
with all that
I'm getting surprised everyday so
I feel like we need to do networking here
just call it a day
this right here
I think the fact that we don't set the
private Network means it is to DHCP means
it's not using DHCP
as this is why I think it's happy I think
the default doesn't have this
yep there it is right there
the default private number type is host only
Network because those are the easiest to
work with
and where's the boxes you can create
multiple social networks it is possible to
specify
it's supposed to say which was the only
Network you want a bigger box for by giving
her face to do this the name argument the
name name hostname Enterprise use
so I think that's what's happening
how's it going what how do you say the name
just like 9 years old 18 freshman majoring
in CS
nicest shark I don't know about changing
your major way to go by if you go by Jacque
joking
yeah that's a that's an important thing to
know
BMT said it much better than me pudding is
not computer science
computer science enables coding but you
won't learn how to code a sunspots very
rarely
so if you want to actually do something
practical
might want to get out of Cs you might want
to actually study an industry that you want
to be in fashion Pharmaceuticals music study
the industry going to major in the industry
and then learn the coating that goes with
the industry
don't if the industry you want to get in is
academic computer science and Quantum
computing
or writing programming languages and things
like that then computer science make sense
otherwise it doesn't make any sense
you want to you know you have to decide what
you want to do
it's like it's like majoring in carpentry
right
hey Sean
they're not even the same network I don't
think they are
why is he has yeah if you can find something
is applied or the major that I like is
computer engineering
my friend my my friend that I've met her for
a long time game
he's in he's in a computer engineering major
and it's really cool it's really practical
it's like electronical engineering with
regard to computer science
I don't know I think this has to be
explicitly provided
all right let's go for this virtualbox
Wholesale in that works
but I be a dad and and to try to Ping
yeah we can try that goddamn I
I know that that's a lot of work that I
don't want to do
I'm at 8 Saturday I want to get to the NFL
stuff I need to stop fucking around
everything I like it at 6. I love your
guys's help but I want to get past this I
got to get used to the point which other
Provisions in a guy pees like it's supposed
to
if your engineering no I don't
I mean if you do computer engineering you'll
not only get electrical engineering skills
but it'll be a computer science skills and
coding skills you learn seeing you learn
assembly and then you can take it up from
there you go you python I can do any of you
can do forensics you do security or do
anything
have you had computer engineer near me that
does the sky's the limit after that got two
new magic double major with Computer
Engineering and computer science and
cybersecurity
if you get a double major in line Computer
Engineering and cybersecurity forensics oh
my God the phone and you'll be fine and zero
days within a within a year of that
this is generic L8
yeah if you can figure this out let me know
you're the boss of me and you know what's up
with this stuff you've been very helpful and
BJ definitely earned your VIP
your VIP is a vault dweller nicer appreciate
the help I'm going to try it
I'm going to try it with some more generic
allegra fell hell yeah
yeah me too me too but I want to get to the
other side will have something more useful
tomorrow
I'll be documenting like my my what I
discovered along the way
yeah yeah just like screwing around with it
take you to work
it's like hacking without hacking new swine
understand that works you know
what's schedule I think I might schedule cuz
they don't follow anything on the schedule
and BMV
tomorrow it's on it's on if you go to if you
go to / schedule is still there
I used the I'm using the twist schedule now
yeah I know I'm sad right
yeah. Did you go to
no man if you go to
slash schedule Hey look
there's really only the only two things on
this guy got to look at this is so fun as I
can all the stuff I did this week
yeah so the only I have learn easy we're
going to DC tomorrow night at 11
all day I would love to have you here for
that if you're here original 5 hours of sea
tomorrow so
actually how many how many more days do we
have I think we only have two more days to
get through the whole book we're not going
to make it but
yeah we have two more weeks we have 10 total
hours to get through this ebook we're going
to start doing community's applications
development boost on
Saturday the 5th because that's the new
calendar
and I kind of want to stick to this annual
calendar as best I can
and I will be making adjustments as we go
and we'll definitely go through that for C
faster next year but you know people boosted
that's old point right and get them get them
gone and they can make blasteroids compare
notes with other people do these on the
schedule though because I have the I have to
get certified before to July right after all
that money way
cell so that's that's counter
and here is my crazy ass I have a feeling
that if I set up my networking
explicitly that is going to get past all the
problems we've been having
I don't know that for sure though so we're
going to go figure that out
we have been doing a lot of it if it's stuff
that I want to throw that out but
we need to we need to change the networking
and every single example I've ever read on
bigger it has the networking explicitly
defined and I think that might have been
causing everybody to bypass the years that
I've been having like supposed to be sending
JCP instead of host base
but I'd rather not add static IP so
definitely you know what
if we have static IP that's going to fix the
other provisioning issue as well
no talking about because now we know what
the eye peas are yeah
oh my God is awesome that looks so fantastic
yeah I I I ride fast but I'm a mess
I'm pondering this situation because
situation because if we're going to send a
pin at first we have to know the eye peas
nothing know the IP of the NFS Mount point
so
I'm really glad you mentioned that because
if we if I go down the path of like setting
up me to no default IP DHCP networking
through vagrant I have no predictable method
of using the IPS and therefore can't
provision things like anifest using a
persistent internet using an unknown IP
address if I do static IP
I know well those numbers are and I can put
them in my provisioning script
then say maybe is me
you think it's built into the unique is
Baker anything is built into the image I bet
it's in the image
let me know if it's amazing how do we how do
we set the static IP in the provision Crypt
is that something I was hoping that I need
to do it though
8288 e
are we looking at
vagrant destroy
nope
I'm here we go a private Network
prominent organelle supplies used to be
sober and has its own step dad
he's given the private owned Vehicles still
get an IP address from the IP space so we
can access to be a recluse and happy for the
hostess of your pride or hustling and
working favorite the static IP address to
open a big of a file to following
going to uncommon it
I mean replace strip
take a private Onsen I work in favor of a
secretary telephone line uncommented
is that set the network IP for this
particular VM
I need to I need the income at the number by
one or something
do you want to see a medically-induced if
you modify see you can set the IP
specifically on the private Network
that's actually what we want to do
I mean I guess it used to be for the workers
and then I could sit for the control I could
set the IP to be a specific number
yeah we just make sure it's on the same just
make sure it's on the same address right
where I can file for the following line and
gun
I meant to make you just recited them in
order to find the IP of emu needed to SSH
into it and use IP cam in so
I think this is a default but I'm going to
add it just to be check
and by the way it is taking so long to
provision it should not take that long
my weather
I don't know what if we did all of them that
way
I don't think we need bass Michael's know I
just think we need to be at Dave sleepy pics
of working longer for vision
I said Charles sit through all this again
make a note watch this go go go
say what we learn a lot about bigger than
all this is happening hey looking at
generating Mac address for Nat networking
setting the name to blah
this is some static IP a look at that
adapter 10 solihull sound like that's
different than you had before
I knew I am going to send some static IP
snacks that's can be the next thing I want
to see what DHCP address is what it gives it
because it's what I'm thinking of doing is
setting a static IP on the control in the
one with the NFS amount and then
and then let him know when to pick up from
DHCP weather for I don't know
I do not know
it's on acrylic or God damn it's cold
as cold where's my blanket
for freezing and because it's like 3 in the
morning
I got to put this on my legs I need my long
underwear on so I need
that's what I really need
I hope everybody's having a great evening
I'm having a blast this is really fun I
can't I've been wanting to do this stuff for
a long time so
if I get in good with Baker and I think is
is worth it
I can't imagine doing all of the same stuff
with ansible as well
you only can imagine doing automating the
creation of volumes with ansible
how would you even do that it's a VM thing
you know
but that alone makes me like more prone to
I'm going back and forth is like a love-hate
relationship with ansible I mean with with
vagrant right
is it for an STD and it doesn't interesting
interested thank you for sharing that haven
that's that's like an advantage for using
Linux right it's because it doesn't do is
have her game
is images of a green. Or. or
that be fun to try and be trying this on a
Mac as well pretty soon
I think I broke it I'm wondering whether
this is the reason I'm going through is
afraid to decide whether to use hyper kit on
Mac or to use virtualbox
cuz you can only I'm pretty sure you can
only have 1 hypervisor install it one time
and running at the same time I guess
now they know because it delivered problem
but that was I had virtualbox running and I
was trying to deliver at stuff and one of
them was using the hypervisor and it
wouldn't let it until I shut down all the
other stuff on the box
know that being everywhere why
why should I be using no. Everywhere and
everywhere
no. VM provider
alrighty I wasn't sure you could actually
change that
I bet you that's more than everything was
all fucked up
that's why I have three more diapers instead
of one year yeah let me try that
Renegade X PNG is Angela a single large be
in
cruising with that yeah that's what I've
been trying to do that kind of thing as well
I don't want any cleanup destroy Vegas get
you mad at me
you know I got two boxes at least twice as
slow as liver is a liver provider
hey look and only has one of them for now
why is it doing host only
just tell her to box interesting it's a
different
ever be able to use hyper kit and minikube
for stuff but I'm going to I'm pretty sure
I'm going to be recommending virtualbox for
everything just because it's so Universal it
might have bugs and stuff but it's really
coming across os's
you know so I don't know
I don't know what I do there
do The Offspring of civilians are greyed out
I did it with half of you being installed
but I haven't been able to the sun assault
yeah
I think you're right it's that's that's
you're talking about Windows right yeah I
think you're right
I think if you do wsl2 it automatically
burns your hyper-v
I could be wrong on that that's changed so
many times in the past 3 years
it was a time when you live when VMware on
virtualbox I mean sorry and we have so too
can exist coexist in a VMware change
everything I think that same poor thing
happened with her two box but hell no
it's the second such a moving Target yeah
I'm almost positive that wsl2 burns your
hyper-v it is soon as you do that you can't
do anything else
and then you get VMware VMware because the
professional product they came out with a
version of it that supports is being on
there
and I don't know what they do and they
probably detect with her W so she's in the
hyper-v and use w72 instead it's only thing
they can do because there's only one thing
can use the hypervisor
so that be interesting to figure
outinteresting to figure out sugar down
there
this is taking longer cuz I did all that I
did all the software installation to
provisional is stuff
yeah I could have used an image or I
probably will do it this is I wonder if I
could just back her to make an image and
then use to put that image up
I bet you I could do that
I bet you I could use Packer to make an
image that has all the stuff this snapshot
that I want and then use that instead of
having to do all of this you know I am up
grade stuff
installing a message if you pass through
when it's been I thought I did I didn't 2013
inside play Dota 2 on my Linux machine cuz
it was Windows only
we just gave maker which is when there's
only two years of that pass-through it's
been harder for me to figure out I haven't
been able to figure out how to do that
lately but the games that I player are
Lennox support it anyway all of them
Witcher Witcher is it Windows only thing but
it proton works just fine
I'm tempted to go play a little bit right
now I want to get this to work though this
is like super super interesting
hey how's it going to John's I trust his
unpaid what the fuck kind of name is that
join the club
people have the craziest names I swear some
of the names I can't read but some of them
just make me giggle
crazy people
what are you doing here hopefully you're
doing something fun and not freezing like me
I'm freezing all I know it's a joke name
is is like Allen sharted his pants
Insurance in Sioux Falls
I mean I have to keep telling myself this
would take me five times as long if I were
doing it on a physical system
is it have zero debt it's a it's it's bad
for the economy to have zero dead
do I code yeah it does look like it right
now but I do code you I do a little of
everything
yep not well
I don't know whether they are many languages
are going to be going to see tomorrow for 5
hours yeah you join us tomorrow or am I
awesome
in front of me School let me see the hoodie
beware the hacker
I'm coming after you
all right why is it take you so long
hacker man
does hackerman have a plushie
brought to you by Mozzy K thank you Marcus
again for buy me my plushie keeps my heart
rate down I'm going to live an extra year
because of this
getting at least terminal good for you
here's some
I don't mean to sound condescending I really
don't
kind of plushie this is a special plushie
yeah it purrs
and it and it it's a purse ya hear it
hey a purse
and it talks oh it's so damn cute
this is what this is what keeps this will
keep my blood pressure down
plus she's not even kidding you can take
drugs you take Prozac and Xanax or whatever
the fuck or you can get a
or you can get a plushie or 2 or 10 or 50
Lego age on that's that's that's my take on
Terminal if you want to learn Linux terminal
and go watch that made a whole bunch of
videos
you can take it or leave it but I made him
and go watch him
and we do it again we're going to do we can
do this again on May 4th so Saturday is a
beginner Dame Saturdays are boost days 11 to
load of whatever 3 meeting tomorrow didn't
see
message I don't do two girls I'm a big bash
band bash is the default show on trillions
of Linux systems at this point
I would say billions and billions doing
something that Millions
my so that's why you should learn bass first
in my opinion the people disagree but
yeah she want to get started what you fixed
it
he fixed it why is he pastebin I can't copy
it into my my config
you Zeke's please for something that's not
shit
is that or tell me what I have to curl to
get to get it cuz I can't curl it right I
don't like that I can't curl oh I can curl
it you sent me the wrong link I take it all
back thank you that's wonderful
don't do that tell people usually don't send
me the real link
Disney for clothes through baby
each with index name index you gave it a
number oh you wonderful person you
this is beautiful this is so beautiful
this is very beautiful yes I find a
beautiful this is I have a strange idea of
beauty but this is definitely beautiful
I just hit the next and auto city AP
yes I like the next that's the part I
noticed the first yes he's right so much we
do this girl a paste watch the magic people
I am now going to magically convert the line
of code into its output using a filter to
man which is! And sending you the bash boom
and I get it all I should have put an S
there I got the shit out of me then why do
we have control arms in their pastebin is
shit
please finish it you and your mat are you on
a Windows machine you are
look at the guy these control ends this is
his character during this means somebody
edited this thing on a Windows machine
which is unacceptable
so so we will steal your ideas and write
them here in a proper way
it's with an X
yeah I know I didn't know you could do two
of the same time
I'm learning more Ruby everyday
I knew it really well once upon a time and I
just do not remember a single fucking thing
that's the same that's the same that's not
the same
best magazine will you skip the gcp stuff
right right my turn this off for a second
where's the Vox Lynx cloned truly Peace by
the way
so yeah it was unfortunate
a passkey Peru to to to-do to do at work
but where did you put this you put it in
here right
all right when I say how did you know I'm
going to run into Network
it is an object can write each of the next I
did not know this I did not know this
distro Unix it's what's your exam I using
star Starks do you speak Russian or French
you can change it I don't think I don't
think I can though you know what
can I get can I give it IP to the host
Network and then just haven't been on the
same thing
I could write you're mean
Odessa Unix yes I know but that one
nothing else yes yes yes thank you now I'm
yeah I totally forgot about that it's an
ancient tool he can also just do that with
like any basic filter
command so yep that's really cool let's just
say I want to see what
I want to see we ended up with though so are
our thing is finished running Ice I believe
where are we is it for no it's some
and then where is it if they don't have
anymore all right let's go
some sexy itis yeah that's one
and if you see Bridget working yeah but I
really don't care they just going to be able
to vagrants status we should have three
systems up hip
where's my for Loop for I control or i p g
i mean rip ivy
qh0
yeah he was in 2 p.m.
nothing new no no dice
all right so this is not resend you a piece
which I didn't expect it to not understand
how that works
but I thought it would be worth a look we
decided to do CPT at 10 do it
and what was the scary about this doctor
oh wow it totally it is it tastes if he
works
dish DP totally works
if you do it again
I think your ETA 27% better that's weird
I find this interesting why is this one
still there
so this is the DHCP route to God about it
and I got picked up for my local internal
Network by the way that's really cool you
know that means that means that the because
my IP is on that as well
yeah yep C
I'm on the one I sent 16 a number that means
that means that it picked up the DHCP from
I want to say from my internal my internal
IP server
asme interfaces on here because the
virtualization started hard to know but
yeah when I said what she say you made a
pawn game in a code awesome
is this 24 yeah it is so different I just
think I'm confused by his why does it still
have the $10 address you see that
and I know we're kind of like you know just
just like playing with the mysteries of
networking right now but why did it still
allocate attend. No org I think the 10th.
Network must have been a part of the image
what do you think hitting the 10. Networks
and you need to 10. Networks need to buy it
it's okay this is this is this is the
address that was assigned 9 10 11
3 days to pee and that is a
and we and I had different internet
addresses course so I'm pretty sure the
other festival at work now but I like your
about your way better
never seen her face is always at her face
they're both that interfaces
let me think about that for a second
okay I think you're saying
are you saying you're saying that all three
hosts are as if they're on an internal
Network and the knotted then that is
external facing IP is 10. 2. 15 is what have
the same one
okay that makes sense I am looking in the
verse of ox
so that's what this is let me know we can go
in and look around some more
oh oh oh oh
but I'm just wondering normally when
something is normally when something is not
it in here
it means that it has an IP that's
internal to this machine and then you know
there's some sort of common IP for the
machine that but brokers in but the fact
that they have the same IP makes it there's
some extra level of
there's some extra Network layer inside of
the computer the second that within the net
sort of thing going on it seems like to me
but I don't know yet. I see that the first
one is not
and the second adapter is the house only
adapter view box net that's interesting
I'm still in a
at the school high school it doesn't matter
fault
alright so
so that's good that's good we're making
progress
that's really knows what she was just added
to your truck so I got to get that right now
okay so that's that's when I saw that it's
like vagrant has its own that in addition to
that to the other one and that's that's what
it has to do with the problem with this is I
can't predict that it's always going to be a
one 92.9 the address and less I mess with my
DHCP ride or something I don't want to do
that so I'm going to redo this one last time
and after that I'll probably give up for the
evening I mean it's been really fun
and
I really really like that you're assigning
the IP to an exact number because then I can
know the number and I can use it in the
controller
when it in my provisioner and 78 when I
scraped the Manifest up I can I can
hard-coded to those kinds of things
so yeah
yeah I'm just thinking here
yeah I told anybody to buy peas and so you
solved that problem appreciate that
and let's pray that and if we can actually
go the NFS stuff
psycho the NFL stuff we can start over with
Benefits tomorrow which is good because I've
been feeling all the RPC stuff and
everything that we are hitting it just going
to all go away just going to all go away and
won't do that little thing again with this
is he
I'm going to try one more thing and call it
a day
it's a stew
no it's two vagrant I'm I'm losing brain
power here and it's time for me to go watch
a movie to go to bed and then I'll come back
bright and early tomorrow and we'll do some
more stuff in at 11 we're going to be doing
see Cody all day
I'm take this down
destroy again I'm going to restart it when I
get a break till I pee and after that we're
going to go to town
and then eventually will strip the F this
creation and all the while will sing A Merry
Little tune
I'm freezing I really I'm going to go cuddle
with my plushie and watch a movie and fall
asleep I wish I could take you all with me
but I can't watch movies with you cuz twitch
sucks
actually it's not too much that sucks it's
it's dcrm sucks
Olivia by watching I have gotten sucked into
this keep them close
detective British detective kind of thing
this mystery is murder mystery thing I might
kind of sucked into it lately and I I know
it's like it's good it's good it's really
well written
I got a lot of legs turns into a cinch it
what was the last thing I watched before
that though
boost versus Murder She Wrote it kind of is
actually it is it is with a lot more you
know risque
I just listened to the British accents a
modern modern British accents are so sexy
I just have to stop and go to lie I just
love listening to it just so much so
pleasant to listen to
I just makes me realize how harsh American
accents are we are really
just the bottom of the barrel are are
diphthongs slurs and shit
I was the one who washed before that I was
watching
I mean I don't I don't know how I want to
start reading here's a problem I don't see
anybody has this problem but I'm a big I'm
an Avid Reader but I only read when I'm in
the tub and our tub is broken I haven't been
reading
I know that sounds weird I love to sit in
the tub and read it like you know like a
cliche woman with bon bons is he like an
American like we like those say I don't use
bubble bath or anything but I just like
that's another thing I like to like roll up
and get cozy and read problem is is it by
the time I'm done with the shit like this
I'm staring at the screen here even though
I'm I can't quite explain it but
I I kind of have an inversion for looking at
text
it makes no rational sense whatsoever
glass of wine a good book absolutely
absolutely why does it have to be for women
why can't men do that
I fucking love that I love it it's one of my
favorite thing and I'm fucking freezing
right now and I'm missing my bathtub my
bathtub doesn't work it doesn't work cuz I
live in this shity apartment
I have to stop saying that this apartment is
as Apartments go it is not horrible that
I've lived in worse
but again I also have lived in you know
pretty ritzy area the suburbs for very large
portion of my life I can't wait to get an
can't wait to get an actual house again can
I just say I'm looking so forward to that
I'm really looking forward to that
sigh sigh sigh sigh
oh Firefox that's what I was watching make
your mama cry
yeah I'm I'm on exit have it up right now
yeah Firefly
I was really a very watching Firefly you
talk about Cozy man Firefly is so cozy
is my son calls it the Western Cowboy Bebop
I need to watch the original anime Cowboy
Bebop 2 cuz I watch the whole the whole
thing and I never got it you know it's funny
with firefly I got into it I did not get
into the first time I watched it and the
second time I watched it because my wife was
an avid Avid person into it Farscape yeah if
you could do she got so into it as I've come
and give us another try it so I watched it
with different eyes the Brilliance of
firefly is the writing writing is just
amazing it's really really crazy amazing
writing then there's so many little Nuance
mess comments and everything and like the
second time you fire fireflies really really
rewatchable because there's just so much in
there that's like multiple layers is a
couple of doses that are really don't like I
I don't like the which one some episodes of
like really really good compared to I love
the episode where
Kaylee gets the dress and the girls are
making fun of her and the baron comes over
and put the girls in their place by saying
and then he says he can't wait to see Kaylee
and goes because I cannot abide useless
people
play I'm hooked on a shirt I want that on
the shirt man I get out and I cannot abide
useless people and then she has a black
winning over the hearts of all the men
because she knows everything about the
engines shows everything about the engines
of the ships that she's over there on her
big pink dress you know eating all kinds of
food and stuff and just winning the hearts
of all these guys because she knows so much
about about the mechanical energy of the
ship and are they should just so cool that
it's just got such a crazy amazing character
development and I'm a big fan of character
development I I'm a super big sucker for
character development
it if it's if you send me doesn't have Scott
shallow characters and it just tries to have
somebody run around and shoot everything I
don't get into it as much the reason the
Marvel movies work so well is because of the
character development in my opinion
otherwise our kind of shallow and tinian so
I kept it like if you compare if you can. We
were watching we have HBO Max lately if you
compare like all the hbos stuff too
are you going to compare all the the DC
stuff right
I did give her all the DC stuff to the
Marvel stuff the character Generation
generation just did all this just like
non-existent and that's why they suck so bad
and I like just horrible
but everything else is the same right it's
really pretty look especially Aquaman
Aquaman has like more character generator
and development did some of the other ones
but you know but all this you know the CGI
and and how pretty it is to watch all that
stuff's all there but then it just doesn't
come through with with the character says
that's why I guess my guardians of galaxy
kicked ass that's why they added BatDad of
that kind of thing in Ragnarok and all the
other stuff is just you got to have
characteristic my opinion
so it's also the reason that all of the the
Star Wars sequels just fell on your fucking
face there was no character moment that's
that's why I like Rogue one so much better
it did so much better at its character
development and Rogue one I feel like we're
going to start that you cared about the
characters
I was I can't get into it
I love Rogue one Rogue ones probably white
one of my if not one of us is from in my
all-time favorite Star Wars except for the
very first one but you can't I can't get the
very first ones I love solo
I love so everybody hated it I loved it I
love solo
and there's so many people found reasons to
really hate itfind reasons to really hate it
I loved it
I really really love solo it's yeah I didn't
I still like Rogue one better
I like Rogue one better because it's a
tragedy it's a tragedy also at the end of
Rogue one ohmygod
Amy kisses makes my heart just fluttered
like crazy
the scene the final scene of Rogue one has
got to be one of the best scenes in all of
Star Wars and it's and it's it's the best
scene because it was made in modern times
where they could show violence
and the reason it's so amazing to a guy who
saw the original Star Wars and 76 you know
20 times as a twelve-year-old is because
it was when Vader comes through the door
he's so harsh and it's so violent and
there's just so much excitement from the
very first seen the very first scene that's
that's where this ship comes from right
that's where this ship the ship is the very
first scene this is my favorite scene All
Star Wars this very first unit is this this
Corvette is getting blockade-runner right
and
and Vader boards and everything if it's the
fact that they provided the backstory to
that scene and they made that most amazing
scene in Star Wars even better
oh oh my God that was just like
I I thought I was going to come unglued
watching that I was already like crying my
eyes out because you know if you haven't
seen it they die right and and then and I
was so sad because it cuz they died and then
and all this emotion and then I saw that
scene and then immediately made me want to
go watch Star Wars you know A New Hope but
you can't watch A New Hope because Lucas is
a fucking prick
I hate Lucas I mean he gave us all that shit
but he also fuck this over Lucas ruined my
childhood he like made it so that we could
have watched the original Star Wars anymore
we still can't you still can't get the
fucking original you can't get it you have
to watch that shity kid Teensy they replaced
in there or are you can't get the original
thing that I saw 25 times I don't want any
of your remastered fuck shit I just want the
original give me the original he wouldn't
even give it to him he wouldn't even give
the original he was asked by the Smithsonian
to give the original and he refused to do it
because he wants it to be dead he wants to
be dead he wants to place is so persistent
publicly says it's my right on the Creator
and I'm like you know what soon as you
release sent to the rest of the fucking
world you made a committed relationship with
the rest of us and now we're on love with
that thing and I paid you hundreds of
dollars to see your piece of work and now
you're going to fucking take that away from
me you piece of shit I hate Lucas I have
nothing good to say about that
I hate it because money-grubbing piece of
shit he ruined our childhood and he he he he
came along and he just he started out being
an amazing Visionary and he gave a Star Wars
and I'm grateful that I always will be
grateful for that but then
but I know there's a despecialized Edition I
know about it I know all about it I know I
studied it I studied it for like a week now
is trying to find it on tauren and download
it and everything and get the do you
socialize I know there's like tons of videos
about the comparisons about which
despecialized Edition yet and there's
there's rumors we were leaking out here but
there's there's rumors actually that that
Disney now that this has got a hold of it
they're going to do the right thing because
there's like an overwhelming dizzy made
despecialized Edition for a special showing
to some like high paying fucked some place
did you see this Disney did it Disney made a
despecialized Edition 2 for a special
showing and not so there's rumors that
they're going to actually you know do it I
tell you what I would pay Disney more than
$100 for a copy of The unmastered Originals
with nothing touching them at all with their
I don't maybe you know some digitization
there's no theatrical cut of 45 and 6 that's
actually there is a theatrical cut but the
thing is is that there are so many so the
despecialized Edition is one where these
like really intense fans have come together
and they've gotten all the despecialized
editions of everything and then they
remaster them digitally as well top of all
of that but there's no other changes there's
no CGI there's no Edition solo shots first
who shots first all of that stuff it's all
the original it's got they didn't take
didn't you know what they even took it to
you until Kathy's song out of Return of the
Jedi at the end that with the with the
spaceship flying in the in the in the
defects and everything and I got out I have
angry because I can't even reproduce that
wonderful night of my childhood anymore I'm
renting for no reason but it just it just
pisses me off that somebody would come along
and think that they could do that that's not
a god
yeah I mean yeah that wasn't a good thing we
got the the thing that made it so amazing is
what they did with it is always looking at a
drawable you know what you would didn't age
well early shity CGI that's when did age
well
that's what made it so magical with me just
so magical is it it was done with by
puppeteers all his work from all the people
that could think about this think about this
for a second I am just a fan. Can you
imagine being one of the people who created
those original Puppeteer scenes and the
stuff from the original Cantina scene and
all that stuff and all was just thrown out
there just for I can you
and then all of a sudden you have it
replaced by this horrible horrible CGI those
people who spent their you know there's the
better part of their lives making that or
come to life and then get Luke Lucas comes
along and throws that shit all out because
it's his baby it's not their baby it's his
baby cuz he's a dick is a I can't even talk
about him because he just thinks he can come
is more crucial even though it's not your
fucking creation is something you started
and you got rolling and then all of the
hundreds of people who created that thing
are the people who created you piece of
motherfucking shit
he came along and he just threw all their
artwork out the window and all of our
memories with it cuz he thinks he can cuz
he's George fucking Lucas Creek
I can't think about this anymore it's time
for me to go to bed
it makes me so angry I can't think about
your there's other things to be angry about
that are more important B get her stand
these I bonded with Star Wars as a
twelve-year-old it was probably the most
significant work of art in my entire life
as a twelve-year-old I related to Luke I
related to his struggles with the force in
getting funding who he was and everything so
for my generation
that series some people Bond like that with
Harry Potter series some people have bonded
that way with the Percy Jackson series some
people about it that way with you know
whenever there's people Bond differently
with different things are raised as they're
growing up but the reason I get so I ask
myself why am I so angry about this
the reason I'm so angry is because he's
fucking with my childhood
and and that's not cool it's not cool Song
of the South yeah yeah yeah
yeah Song of the South is a scary 12 though
yeah I know that's
how rare are rabbits that I mean you know I
understand why some of that stuff needs to
be changed in modernizes because
In-N-Out I mean there's legitimate reasons
to that kind of thing but there was no
reason for that one
there was no reason for that one
I don't even like Star Wars anymore tell the
truth I don't I don't because my my my Star
Wars represented a different set of ethos a
different eat those that I had once upon a
time I don't have that ethics anymore
but I haven't seen Star Wars at all I don't
disapprove of that at all actually I would
suggest you not watch it
if anything I suggest you watch Mandalorian
mandalorians a fucking work of art it's
amazing
and seriously I I cannot recommend Star Wars
anybody you know and I am really really wish
that they had steam rolled over the guy who
was going to do Last Jedi the way he wanted
to tip for a modern generation they they
came in and they ripped his control away and
took it and try to salvage it and it made it
into a Joss Whedon like remake and just Joss
Whedon who made fireflies live in Sweden
anymore he's not just weird and he's become
the guy who saves movies from the box office
bankruptcy you know
Amanda Martin to think of something about
Mandalorian is
fluoride is is totally unique it stands
completely on its own it's got this sort of
winter it's got a completely different story
line is God it's got a different set of
ethics and principles and it still has a ton
of nods to the old Star Wars generation so
you know something that might have been like
in one seeing like you know like the the the
the Bounty Droid right you know gets one
scene in in all of Star Wars and all of a
sudden he gets like a full in a fight scene
and so to the people like me that nod to the
former Star Wars generation is really nice
if Jon Favreau his he's a genius man that
guy is a genius
I mean you know he has done so many amazing
things Fargo how do you say his name
he sent so many amazing things
I just watched the making of the movies that
made us and there was a movie that he
talks about in there I can't remember the
name of it now he actually
it is one of his is one of his first movies
they had to make which one was it I can't
remember
this works by the way so there's. Two and
three and four so we're ready for an FS
tomorrow I'm going to say this
I think you do BJ
a house is not a good or evil shit music
that's super dangerous
I guess I waited too long and then
oh God
are the production of goods and then
Mandalorian is fucking awesome and the
writing is just amazing it could it's so
good
the right I have to have good writing I'm
just finicky
I do have to get ready to die alone as I've
said overwhelmingly many times
god dammit
I don't want to admit that get
how do I remove them
I can't remember the commands I found I know
they can I think it's on the stage right
when is it
remove
I mean even if it deleted I don't care
now it's it's stage something
I don't remember the trance what day did the
Doctor Who
I haven't seen the new and I could see how
you could get into that though
damn I I likes. A little bit of Doctor Who I
didn't get really into it but I I totally
get it it in the problem is is like it's
whatever it is that you associated with your
childhood and people start fucking with it
and you can't recall it anymore you can't
pull it up and then you start getting angry
it's like they're just sitting on your
childhood and they are don't care as long as
it doesn't make money
it's like him damn it how do I
remove file from fit I should remember this
I don't know I don't do that much
how to remove files from your command
git reset soft head now fuck now
AmeriCash if someone interested in this
filing or you can do this in order to create
to delete the file from the index
R & S trash cashed it I just cashed
vagrant
okay status now where we got that's much
better
okay Schmidt
and
alright j3po create weight
j.h. repo create Dash D
had a national one readme.md
I'm just said change the
initial space
I'm like yes yes are we go
I'm going to make sure that made it up so it
went to get pushed gift for stachiw origin
Maine
and we have something
so that makes me feel better I can sleep at
night I will return it to the NFS tomorrow I
should be enough history quickly when I wake
up probably around 11 truly set an alarm
I slept already a little bit tonight so
don't anybody worried
wake me up at 10:30
alright thank you
and I think I think we're going to go
all set I mean really read so I'm just going
to go to bed here pretty Scotland
I haven't seen anybody on right now cuz it's
middle of the night
otago B on
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
who else is on
don't nobody else that I am really
interested in Reading
so I'm just going to take off it's been
really great thank you everybody all right